this is jaco podcast number 110 with
echo Charles and me jakka Willick good
evening echo good evening all Sciences
have principles and rules war has none
the great captains who have written of
it give us none extreme cleverness is
required to even understand them and it
is impossible to base any judgment on
the relations of the historias
historians for they only speak of war as
their imaginations painted as for the
great captains who have written of it
they have attempted rather to be
interesting than instructive since the
mechanics of war is dry and tedious
books dealing with it have small success
and their merit will not be recognized
except after the passage of time those
writing historically of war have better
luck
they are sought by all the curious and
kept in all libraries that is why we
only have a confused idea of the
discipline of the Greeks and Romans war
is a science covered with shadows in
whose obscurity one cannot move with an
assured step routine and prejudice the
natural result of ignorance are its
foundation and support nothing is so
disgraceful as slavish Ness to custom
this is both a result of ignorance and a
proof of it Chevalier foulard supposes
all men to be brave at all times and
does not realize that the courage of the
troops must be reborn daily that nothing
is so variable and that the true skill
of a general consists of knowing how to
guarantee it by his dispositions his
positions and those traits of genius
that characterized great captains
perhaps he reserved of this immense disk
perhaps he reserved discussion of this
immense subject and perhaps all
so it escaped him nevertheless it is of
all the elements of war the one that is
most necessary to study the same troops
who if attacking would have been
victorious may be inevitably defeated in
entrenchments few men have accounted for
it in a reasonable manner for it lies in
human hearts and one should search for
it there no one has written of this
matter which is of the most importance
the most learned and the most profound
of the profession of war and without a
knowledge of the human heart one is
dependent upon the favour of fortune
which sometimes is very inconstant so
those are some opening words from a book
called reveries on war by Maurice de
sacs this guy's a character Maurice de
sacs you did a little research on him
did you find out how much of a character
he was he was a serious character
there's a couple things there's a couple
things even in that opening right there
that I wasn't sure if I was gonna cover
this now it's kind of like going back to
it to see if it was something we should
cover but I just when you get right here
all Sciences have principles and rules
war has none that's a true statement
and it's true that there's you know
there's principles of warfare but
there's no actual rules like you can do
whatever you want I mean you can say
that you need a convention but then you
can justify it and just you know you can
do things that are completely opposed to
it so there's no rules you should do
whatever you want to win yeah now you
could lose your respect and you could
act inhumane and that might cost you in
the long run but if war is war there's
no other thing like that mm right
there's no other thing like that do
whatever you want I guess if you had a
if you had like a street fight with no
weapons and someone's gonna do whatever
they could to win right
the thing it's that's war it's the same
thing yeah yeah when you do with like
death
is kind of the goal and the consequence
at the same time like death that's the
end of the line so yeah anything goes
essentially yeah yeah no clues like that
then he says this nothing is so
disgraceful as slavish NIST accustomed
that's a bold statement - mm-hmm
I agree disgraceful he calls it he talks
about these prejudices that people have
I think you call him what do you call
him by biases right cognitive biases he
talks about he doesn't talk about that
but he talks about them but this guy was
a character he lived from 1696 to 1750
he started off as a German soldier in
the army of the Holy Roman Empire which
was like this bunch of territories in
Europe that were banded together under
that name and they were that around for
a long time from like the Middle Ages
until the time of the Napoleonic Wars so
you know the early 1800s and he served
also served in the Imperial Army which
was another kind of army that often
fought alongside the army of the whole
and Holy Roman Empire anybody but the
weird thing is is he finished his career
as the marshal general of France and so
he kind of I guess you could say he kind
of switched sides but he rose rose up
through the ranks because his military
career started at the age of 13 when he
fought at the Battle of Malpeque hey I
think that's how you say it which and
that that war that battle right there
was that was between the army of the
Holy Roman Empire and France so he was
on both sides at certain points of his
life and I think the whole time he was
it seems like from what I read about him
he was always kind of looking to go up
the social structure
you know rate rise up in the social
structure and become more a powerful
person mm-hmm in the hierarchy of those
times in the dominance hierarchy so yeah
he started fighting at age 13 which by
the way at that's just so cool I don't
I'm sorry if you think I'm a bad person
but as far as I'm concerned if I could
have joined the military at 13 I would
have been
so stoked sorry everyone that's that
doesn't agree with that that's just how
I roll
I'm just telling the truth on that one
and actually as I look back on my life
if I could have done that would've been
even better
I think they shall allow people to join
the military they should have some like
a youth core yeah and go in and just get
after it
you had a young age crap but they think
and they think a thirteen-year-old can't
make that decision and the right the
thirteen-year-old can make that decision
so you'd have to have really benevolent
people that were in charge of them in
charge of these troops and you also
think that an 18 year old person can
make a good decision but if that's not
true you got 18 people that are dumber
than dirt yeah make bad decisions yeah
and people are worried that you're gonna
get thoughts put into your head yeah
yeah you are you are and guess what
if they're good thoughts right on that's
not a bad thing right yeah but I mean do
you have to learn everything yourself is
that the way the world works you can't
have good ideas put in your head you
can't get a little bit programmed yeah
you can get programmed to be a better
human being would you accept that
program yeah of course okay I'm just
checking blood and you're over there
looking like because of that person
because I'm trying to brainwashing no
cuz you're just saying look we're better
good and better like there's this
universal good and better you know there
is no there is I mean there is okay but
it's so narrowly and we have Jordan BPO
here you can converse that you can have
a conversation you say how do you say
that you don't know that there's
universal good and universal no no I'm
saying I mean we could get a sense of
things right now that we know are good
to me yeah child is that good or bad
yeah okay yeah for sure I'm gonna take
something that doesn't belong to you
good or bad yeah but though they're so
basic and fundamental that you know you
don't need a youth core to well there's
a lot of people out there that don't get
taught that stuff and that's true too
but that's a whole different issue okay
well I'm just making sure yeah but if
you're yeah I know you're saying how
you're saying good like good ideas and
good idea you're talking about your way
big no no I was not I would not and I
still even you know I get in trouble for
this because for instance people say oh
you shouldn't wake up at 4:30 in the
morning and I always say like yeah I
know I'm not saying you have to wake up
at 4:30 in the morning I'm saying to
wake up earlier don't be lazy Yeah right
I'm not saying you have to I say
you know don't eat doughnuts right sure
I'm not saying you can never taste
anything that tastes good I'm just
saying be smart man come on you don't
need a doughnut doughnut sorry actually
on the evil they might just be pure evil
too by the way
right come on man possibly
don't let Sony they don't even make you
feel I mean is there any do you get any
satisfaction from a doughnut status Phil
what depends on what you mean by
satisfaction and you all just want to
try and parse these things well you
can't absolutely okay so I guess you get
a ten-second good taste in your mouth
yeah sugar rush yet so so and
technically pay for that yeah your
health and fitness sure so you don't
seem to care no me no man I care Carol
okay I'm just I'm trying to I'm trying
to look at it from all angles
satisfaction yes technically and okay
but you could come up with some
fundamental good things and I'll tell
you this the military does teach some
fundamental good things so if I could
have joined at the age of 13 it would
have been good for me I would've been
stoked actually I would have missed out
on some cool stuff too because I had
some fun back in the jury and I
disappear stuff that actually led to me
being Who I am today you know I learned
but not at what I'm saying the point is
is that your way not everyone will agree
I agree with you okay and I'm sure a
bunch of you but I'm just saying this
like different no I guess I'm not Pro
universal brainwashing to my methods of
Lilith yeah I'm not I'm not which makes
thirteen year old by the way yeah which
is thirteen years now I'll tell you I
just said that that going in the
military I would have missed out on some
things you know maybe some growing up
experiences Maurice de sac didn't miss
out on a damn thing cuz he was getting
after it in many different ways
not only on the battlefield but also as
a little bit of a maniac he was first of
all he was like apparently physically he
was kind of a beast of a man and like
physically any fault
he he kind of proved himself he
distinguished themselves in some big
battles as he was 13 14 15 16 17 years
old apparently he could bend a horseshoe
with his hand and I I was looking at
that I was thinking myself they mean
hands right
they must mean hands yeah they didn't
say that it's at hand and I didn't want
to take anything away from him so
apparently he could grab a huge big and
could grab
horseshoe and just bend it in one hand
so he had some some serious strength and
through his life he commanded companies
at which he actually refers to as
centuries which if you can imagine
century we know that means 100 so a
century it like the ancient Roman army
had centuries
instead of companies and they weren't
even a hundred people they were like 80
people but he led those he led regiments
and he led whole armies and he fought
with a lot of success throughout his
career now with that that being said he
was far from what anyone would actually
consider a role model because he the way
he lived his personal life was not
exactly exemplary exemplary I didn't say
that word right exemplar yes in fact
well the way he lived his life was
probably the opposite of role model so
he was forced into marriage at the age
of 18 he didn't want to get married
because he I think he was a too much of
a womanizer and said I don't want to get
married but he married this heiress
fourteen-year-old heiress with a ton of
money he blew all our money and he was
18 she was 18 she was 14 she was she was
an heiress with a bunch of money he took
all her money and blew it on horses for
his regiment and on women mistresses and
then he had a bunch of public affairs
and everyone kind of knew about it and
the marriage gotten old and he continued
this kind of wanton behavior I think
throughout his life and a couple times
he's hypocritical because in the book he
talks about certain types of people and
I don't know if I cover it but he he
does come across a little bit
hypocritical hypocritical sometimes now
I think one of this is this one quote I
grabbed from this mistress this kind of
famous mistress actually she's
recognized as the chief mistress of King
Louie the 15th so did you know that the
King had like not just mistresses we
know that but there's a chief mistress
who's known yeah her name was Madame de
Pompadour and this is what she said
about sacks maurice de sacs does not
understand anything about the deli
see of love the only pleasure he takes
in the Society of women can be summed up
in one word debauchery so he's a little
bit out of control he might have in fact
inherited his lifestyle choices from his
dad whose name was Frederick Augustus
who was well known for his personal
unbridled lust how do you know that he
had unbridled lust well case in point
Maurice was the eldest Oh Maurice two
sacks was the eldest of 354 acknowledged
illegitimate children that Frederick
fathered so while we might not want to
emulate Maurice to Sax's personal life
he was an experienced and successful
leader of men on the battlefield and we
can learn from him and with that let's
go back to the book and here's Maurice
two sacks a man who has that a talent
for architecture and can design will
draw the plan and perspective of a
palace with great skill but if he is to
execute it if he does not know how to
shape his stones to lay his foundation
the whole edifice will crash soon it is
the same with a general who does not
know the principles of his art nor how
to organize his troops for these are
indispensable qualifications in all the
operations of war the prodigious success
with which the Romans always gained with
small armies against multitudes of
barbarians can be attributed to nothing
but the excellent composition of their
troops not that I would infer from this
that a man of genius will not be able to
succeed even at the head of an army of
Tartars it is much this is the this is
the interesting part it is much easier
to take men as they are than to make
them as they should be it is difficult
to reconcile opinions
prejudices and passions so there's a
couple interesting things I also forgot
to point out that he wrote this kind of
on a whim and he actually starts off
this this whole book hunt he says this
work was not born from a desire to
establish a new method of the art of war
it was composed to amuse and instruct
myself and then one of the last things
he says in the book is to the readers I
wrote this book in 13 nights I was sick
thus it very probably shows the fever I
had this should supply my excuses for
the irregularity of the arrangement as
well as the in elegance of the style I
wrote militarily to and to dissipate my
boredom now on top of those that excuse
right on top of that he was a big opium
user so we're figuring he was probably
right in this an impaired state sure
we're dealing with it we're not we're
not mad about it but we're realistic and
not the reason I say this is because
some of the writing is a little bit
tricky and some run-on sentences and
yeah so we have to part we have to pull
a little bit harder to get some nuggets
but there's plenty of nuggets and I
think that's one of them is much easier
to take men as they are than to make
them as they should be and where I look
at that as a leader you get people that
are good at something mm-hmm and you get
someone that's not good at something but
they're good at something else you put
people where you can use them you put
people where their skills are most
available and where they can where they
can perform their duties to the highest
level because they're naturally good at
it that's all I'm saying I'm not having
you proofread my writing at night right
yeah no no no I'm not and I'm not over
here trying to make videos no no I'm not
write that you see where I'm going with
this yes sorry it would it be easier if
you said you know what Jocko when it
comes to the podcast why don't you come
up with the talking a bunch of talking
and I'll make cool videos right yeah we
kind of did that
yeah otherwise we people be listening to
you
talking about movies from 1988 and
comparing of the stuff yeah clunky which
is you know it's fine yeah but and then
wouldn't you have to expend more
resources in your part to coach me up
yes oh yeah yeah and and I'd be trying
to make videos which I can and I'd be
have to coach a team at yeah we don't
want that no it would make me mad cuz
it's dealing with computers and stuff
yeah I don't mind computers but I don't
like them sure No
so yeah yeah but that's that's a big
part of like why he's saying it though
right because it's like it's like you're
gonna save yourself a lot of time and
headache exactly when you're trying to
coach these guys up when you when you
get to the SEAL Teams it's like oh
you're small a small guy cool you're
gonna be a point man yeah yeah you're a
big guy you're gonna carry an m60 or a
now it's a mark 48 that's what that's
how it's happening we're not gonna take
the small guy and try and get him up
make him taller and bigger and stronger
and we're not gonna take the big guy and
starve him send him to Ranger School so
he loses 38 pounds and he comes back in
like okay you're a point man now no yeah
let's let's use nature he's he talks
about that in other places all right
he's talking about in this section how
to how to raise an army basically how do
you make an army and I thought this
woman was a little bit interesting
because people asked me this question
all the time he's talking about
mandatory service and this is his
opinion on it would it not be better to
prescribed by law that every man
whatever his condition in life should be
obliged to serve his prince and his
country for five years doesn't that's no
joke sometimes people say two years and
that seems reasonable and a lot of
countries do that he says five years and
it's kind of funny his attitude towards
five years back to the book this law
could not be objected to because it is
natural and just that all citizens
should occupy themselves with the
defense of the nation concur no
inconvenience could result if they were
chosen between the ages of 20 and 30
years these are all the years of Liberty
niche when youth seeks its fortune
travels the country and is of little
comfort to parents
this would not be a public calamity
because one could be sure that when five
years had passed discharge would be
granted so he's saying like people
couldn't be mad about it cuz it's only
five years and he's also saying look
this is when your kids are out of
control anyways you might as well have
him in the military there's that that
whole idea of the libertine that took
place back in the day and these guys
would you know basically wild morally
getting after it or I should they were
they were they were they were partying
wicked hard I'm trying to think of a
good way to say it
they were pardon wicked hard with drugs
booze and women yeah The Libertines and
the it was they called them a rake like
if a guy a guy that was out there with a
bunch of different women all the time
they'd be called a rake there's a bunch
of period novels that I had to read
would read when I was in college that's
why I know about it about these
libertine rakes so he continues on this
method of raising troops would provide
an inexhaustible reservoir of fine
recruits who would not be subject to
desertion in course of time as a
consequence it would be regarded as an
honor to have fulfilled one service I'd
say that's probably accurate but to
produce this effect it is essential to
make no distinctions to be immovable on
this point and to enforce the law
particularly on the nobles and the rich
then no one will complain hey you gotta
gonna do it to one person you got to do
to everyone equally consequently those
who had not served their time will scorn
those who are reluctant to obey the law
and insensibly it will become an honor
to serve the poor bourgeois who will be
consoled by the example of the rich and
the rich will not dare complain upon
seeing the noble serve Arms is an
honorable profession
how many princes have borne arms now
what's interesting about this idea is
that there's some people in the world
that aren't really meant for warfare mmm
and so should we let nature I I'm more
I'm more heavily agree with the previous
point you should let people do what
they're good at naturally so you're
gonna end up recruiting people that
might not be good at this naturally yeah
and that's not a good thing but not
everyone was a war right
no you're right you can pretend of
different jobs yeah that's that's
absolutely true they could put the the
guy that's more more apt to be like good
at writing he could become a military
journalist Yeah right
you know people always ask me that
question and the bottom line is it's a
tough one I'm sorry I don't have like
some hardcore stance on it one way or
the other
do I think it would benefit everyone
every eighteen-year-old if they joined
the military it would benefit them I'm
telling you it would benefit them do I
think it should be mandatory I don't
really think so because I don't want to
have a bunch of draftees in the military
and if you don't want to join and you
want to miss out on having that part in
your life that's your call and that's
why this is America you can do what you
want yeah that makes sense huh cuz on
one on one hand you kind of can look at
it as like taxes right where how just
like how this axe was saying you know
you you have to have the perforating the
the the pleasure of the honor to serve
in once your country's defense you know
like that that should be obvious it's
obvious and so it's kinda like consent
compared with paying taxes right taxes
go to public service for all the stuff
and we live in this country we have
public service we all have to pay for it
not just one person here we owe a lot of
people pay a lot more than other people
yeah exactly right not more
yeah that's how the min - you just said
everyone pays their taxes not everyone
pays I know that and it's what if okay
little bit yeah perfect exactly the part
of my point is so let's say I'm like hey
you just pay beautiful it's tax times
from April 15 whatever don't pay taxes
your own just FYI yeah but at the time
we call the quarterly you don't want
that
actually no thankfully all right not
something oh but you know let's just say
for this example in 15 that's what
everyone knows it's alright and you're
like yeah I just made my taxes you know
whatever like I didn't like giving my
mind away but that's it you know just
like people in the in a drastic way
Schnoor matt.taryn
I didn't want to I would rather go be a
rake or whatever and but I'm doing it
and boom I did it and then you got me or
maybe not me someone else saying oh yeah
I didn't pay my taxes yeah and then
you're like well wait wait
you're saying it becomes an honor to pay
your taxes in a way I could agree with
you no no no there's I think there's a
part of your brain no matter how much
you pay for taxes it is like you do have
that feeling like yeah I did my part
even though it sucked even though it
hurt even though you know I would way
rather spent it on a Disney vacation or
something like that like no I would have
rather self into something that was
built more business or something like
that you know just little things like
that no wherever you see what I'm saying
it's kind of the same thing that's one
way to look at it though okay
but the other is one way yeah yeah but
the other way is just like you said if
you get some people who are in there in
the military it was certain like jobs or
whatever and they don't want to be there
yeah it's kind of like it's kind of too
important to have people like that no
but you could have yeah what you said is
actually correct that you could have you
know elements that just did other things
in the military that would be more
aligned with the person's natural
desires of what they want to do
yeah and now there's something in the
Navy called needs of the Navy right so
you get a the the Navy you oh I want to
go get stationed in Hawaii like okay
what are the needs of the Navy because
the needs the Navy come first not you
not your family nothing yeah and and so
the needs and name come first
well yeah and of course same thing with
like a tax situation where it's like
you're if you don't want to do it it's
kind of hard to be like I know you don't
want to do it but hey now that you're
here do what you want you know you can I
can't say that otherwise they'll be like
I don't want to be here so I can choose
what I can do okay I'm gonna do the the
most smallest most light least
time-consuming like basically I'm gonna
do this the least I possibly can because
I don't want to be here to be in the
military this is the vault this is the
mandatory military this will go yes and
it that'll go for it so you're gonna get
these but it's kind of like yes I get
people that would be not doing very much
yeah it's essentially a draft dodger
kind of situation but within you know we
didn't actually dodge it if I'm just
saying if it were a scenario like we'll
just put them where their interests lie
even though they have to be here yes I'm
saying so I'm just saying that's the
other side of the coin where it's like
it's hard to make make it work in an
absolute kind of way Chuck all right you
talked a little bit
clothing troops what they should wear
and this is just I thought this was
interesting our uniform is not only
expensive but very very uncomfortable
the soldier is neither shod nor clothes
nor covered the love of appearance
prevails over attention to health and
this is one of the most important points
demanding our attention hair is a dirty
ornament for a soldier and once the
rainy season has arrived his head is
never dry so it sounds to me like he's
basically saying he doesn't care how
he's looks he's here to win yeah
biggis so hair is a dirty ornament for a
soldier in place of hats I should prefer
helmets as for shoes this was
interesting you know people wear
minimalistic shoes with out with zero
heeled the toe drop have you heard that
expression meaning it's the same level
across so it's any of the barefoot type
shoes okay they all say oh here oh he'll
the toe drop meaning there's not an 8
millimeter difference between the height
of the heel and then it goes down to the
height of the toe this is what he says
as for shoes I would prefer the soldiers
to have shoes of thin level leather with
low heels instead of heavy boots they
would be perfectly shod would and would
March with better grace since the low
heels would force them to turn out their
toes stretch their joints and
consequently consequently draw in their
shoulders it's pretty interesting
because everyone's all in the range of
minimalistic shoes which I actually wear
shoes that don't have any heel toe drop
yeah maybe I'm caught up in that fad but
it's cool but you know what when we were
kids right Chuck Taylors yeah yeah they
have no heel toe drop people so we're
cuz they're good to go that's kind of
yeah I didn't know what the big time
trend you're you're a early adopter yeah
yeah I didn't know but I promised Chuck
chairs are too narrow for me to new yeah
and they don't sell wide ones I've
looked
all right pay what you got to pay people
back to the book without going into
detail about the different rates of pay
I shall only say that it should be ample
it is better to have a small number of
well-kept and well disciplined troops
than to have a great number who are
neglected in these matters it is not the
big armies that win battles
it is the good ones economy can boost P
pushed only to a certain point it has
limits beyond which it degenerates into
parsimony I had to look that word up by
the way
Carson Motors yeah occasionally you get
one of those it means just super cheap
mm-hmm super cheap that's interesting
because that doesn't sound like that
daddy would fall in that category
what is so he if your dad would be
considered parsimonious I guess so I
know that my my dad like many dads will
drive an extra 18 miles to save three
cents a gallon or gas
is it all bad to do that no I don't know
why they don't do that
well yeah you drive eight 18 miles
you're in the ocean all the time but
yeah I've heard of that before
isn't that like a false thing though
like because you drive for sure
kind of pointless you you know you get
the app that has the cheapest gas prices
in your area yeah yeah how much time
you're spending looking at an app that
you paid three dollars for to find out
whether he saved you cents a gallon of
gas yeah now get I get it man I'm cheap
I inherited that right I don't like to
spend money it's hard for me to part
with them with the money right including
the tax man by the way it's offered so I
get it but I also have to have some like
like sometimes my dad could be
irrational about sure you know
irrational just just straight-up crazy
AWOL you could save two cents yeah hey
if you don't need he gets fired up about
that too
yeah that's another thing you know he
always asked me how much that much the
gas out there in California oh my god my
pay for it anyways let's stick the
nozzle in there pull the trigger and
rock it all I got stuff I got a do not
write it
how much cheaper is gas on base he when
I didn't know how much cheaper gas was
on base he was beside himself and then
we found out it was eight cents a gallon
cheaper to get me home basically you
wanna go drive over there wait in line
show your ID and then we get on base you
gotta wait cuz no yeah come on wait is
there because parsimonious parsimonious
yeah huh right use that one but that's
because the because it's like a look
it's like a win right you get a win when
you got oh you think you got the
psychological win yeah yeah yeah no
that's that's definitely that could be
it a little victory yeah I think that is
it because like that too back to the
book hope encourages men to endure and
attempt everything in depriving them of
it or in making it to distance you
deprive them of their very soul
now that immediately made me think of
stalingrad when we were reading about
Stalingrad and the fact that the
soldiers when something would give him a
glimmer of hope it would totally change
their attitude like when they thought
that the German troops were coming to
rescue the the guys that were installing
ground in the pocket in solid rock
yeah they were all excited and they were
you know happy and he literally said
like everyone's morale went up and then
they find out they're not coming it's
just crushed yeah crushed morale yeah
Louie that's based on hope yeah fully
and you kind of see that in like you're
like like I'll work out for example like
if you ever in football we don't like
conditioning right and sometimes they
just be like hey we're just running
sprints wind sprints they wouldn't say
hey we've got ten wind sprints it's not
like that and after a while I guys are
dying and you know not dying but you
don't were getting tired so the Sprint's
are a lot slower towards but they say
two more finish hard for all of a sudden
everybody can run fast again saying even
though you cuz you see that little later
they get about that second is pretty
cool I was kidding eight and then you
watch the hope just go back to being
slow back to the book this is this is
pretty heavy truly the only good
officers are the poor gentlemen who have
nothing but their sword and their cape
but it is essential that they should be
able to live on their pay the man who
devotes himself to war should regard it
as a religious order into which he
enters he should have nothing no other
home than his troupe and should hold
himself honored in his profession so
there you go yeah all in and when people
always ask me especially when I was in
about work-life balance and I'm like eh
I'm not the guy to talk about yeah I'm
not the good person especially when I
was in the military yeah because this
was me you know my number one priority
hundred percent was the team's
everything else was just kind of a your
everyone else is along for the ride but
I know where I'm going
so the being that devoted to war and it
has a power that has a certain it made
you know if you got a guy that's
thinking about all the time I think it
was Jade Jade now we're talking about
something and he said the person who
cares more wins yeah and that's that's
accurate yeah and I want a lot of stuff
in my day just because I cared more I
mean I'm not going to sleep I'm not I'm
just gonna be think about this you're
gonna go home and this weekend you're
gonna go and do a family barbecue and
you're gonna go play baseball with the
kids and blah blah blah and I was just
like no I'm just gonna be doing this all
weekend nobody working on this work
alone I'm I got I care about this yeah
nothing else matters mmm so that's a
again is it healthy for work-life
balance no it's not we're healthy except
for to say if you're that committed to
your work you're a committed person then
that means you're trying to take care of
your family I found necessarily a bad
thing am i reaching maybe yeah I think
okay I'm reaching that's fine you know
marry a good independent woman that
doesn't need emotional support from you
all the time so that she understands
that that was the big thing for me I
think my wife understood that it wasn't
meant as an offensive thing yeah I have
a job
I really care about my job doesn't mean
I don't care about you but my job is
right now and I do that yeah and here in
the work-life balance my just a bad
husband no no because the work life no
because there is no templated time
allotted you know that you need to spend
with these people or those people our
work versus fact there's no like thing
you know sometimes if you're like hey I
need to spend more time with my wife
your wife's like bro go dude leave me
alone you know like we we spent the
weekend together calm down you know go
to work or whatever some people like
that and it's a spectrum so work/life
balance it's like it depends on your
wife and you know in a husband wife
situation you know I suppose instead of
instead of trying to take a life
work-life balance lesson out of this I
think the most important thing to take
out of this is is the level of
commitment right if you're really
worried and successful yeah and not just
talking about war I'm talking about
business I'm talking about life and if
you really want to be successful you
gotta you got to get after it yeah and
you set the other things aside for now
Yeah right just the way it is yeah yeah
sorry all right back to the book
training drill is necessary to make the
soldier steady and skillful although it
does not warrant exclusive attention
among all the elements of war it even is
the one that deserves the least if one
accepts those which are dangerous I try
to figure out that meant I just thought
opium that was an opium ya hit right
there the last part the foundation of
training depends oh this is good but but
okay so drill if you don't think about
the military drill especially back in
those days it was it really was a
necessary thing because you had to
function together as a team in the way
you do that we still do what's called
close order drill in the military now
you've seen it go watch the US Marine
Corps close order silent drill team they
do all these really specific maneuvers
and they have competitions in high
schools between the ROTC classes where
you know you're carrying the rifle you
spin you do that all that stuff that's
called drill yeah the reason it
originated is because you needed for two
reasons number one you actually had to
do those motions on the battlefield
raise your rifle the load Roommate ready
aim fire and then the next rank could be
doing the same thing you had to do in a
coordinated math
and the other reason that they kept
doing it according to my drill
instructor and Officer Candidate School
gunnery sergeant United States Marine
Corps I'll be enough last name was seals
knows his last name great guy
layers the out layers gunnery sergeant
seals my Joe instructor from the United
States Marine Corps and Officer
Candidate School he said the reason that
you're learning this drill is because
the reason that we do drill is because
people need to act instantly upon orders
so it drills into you a level of
obedience when you get told by the left
flank March everyone goes by the right
flank March everyone goes you know so it
teaches you that hey I'm gonna go and
that's what they used to use it for but
they still use it now too so that people
get used to the immediate obedience of
orders now
does that get contradicted by things
that I talk about all the time on here
but questioning orders and making sure
you understand why you're doing yeah it
does absolutely but there is a that's
why that's what it exists for yeah yeah
and at least the capabilities and the
capability is there yes the capability
is there back to the book the foundation
of training depends on the legs and not
the arms all the mystery of maneuvers
and combat is in the legs and it is to
the legs that we should apply ourselves
whoever claims otherwise is but a fool
and not only in the elements of what is
called the profession of arms so
interestingly your personal problem with
people that talk about skipping leg day
it goes back it goes back to here no
thing the big guns the big arms he's
listed it'll help us in the art of war
according to sacks you know why they
call that big for nothing actually big
for nothing in the Y means like I guess
here they say all go no show right so
that's kind of what having big arms and
small legs kinda is as well right
through now you're on board with that
well yeah no I never was keeping legs
day you're the one teasing me and I was
wondering why is that so funny but I
guess yeah that that's why
one bull because you look like a fool
dang yep it goes back yes back a long
time
even back then people were skipping leg
day yeah cuz they were fools
yeah focusing on the wrong thing and it
makes sense even like in those terms
they make sense today let me tell you
something
the the amount looking when I was in the
team so I was running training and I
still talked guys obviously but if you
think about what's going on the Train
like people to people you know I say all
the time like all seal training is not
that hard right I say old I'm like but
I'm talking about buds I'm telling you
the advanced training that you go to
mm-hmm the training that I used to run
it's it's freaking really hard it's
really hard you're in the desert the
desert and don't think of sand think of
rocks think of jagged uneven terrain up
and down hills
yeah then think about your own
night-vision so it's at night think
about you have let's call it about 80
pounds of gear on just on average that's
like the average guys got 80 pounds of
gear on you're going to get dropped off
in the middle of the desert again not
the desert but the rocky what's it
called sub I forget it's it's the rocky
crazy terrain it's hard to walk on in
the daytime it's hard to walk on now
you're at night now you have night
vision on which is great but night
vision is looking far away and you can
adjust when one of your night vision
asides so you have to and you can adjust
one too far and one too close so you can
see a little bit but still your
peripheral vision isn't there mmm your
purview visions gone because there's a
tube in front of your head yeah so you
can't really see what's actually
underneath your feet you can look down
and then you can see it for a second but
you can't walk around looking down the
whole time you got to look at the guy in
front you got a look at you feel the
fire so as you're walking you're making
these micro adjustments all the time to
adapt to your foot hitting the ground in
some weird spot and so you get that and
then you have that weight on your back
and so you get dropped off then you
patrol 10 kilometers 10 kilometers maybe
what's that that's six miles so you're
going six miles then you get six miles
you get to a target area you get to the
target area you got to get eyes on the
target area you know you
get eyes on you climb the biggest hill
around at night being as quiet as you
can you get to the top of that hill you
look at it then you go and assault the
target once you assault the target guess
what you're good for when you're
assaulting the target you're now like
almost running you're running through
the thing at night you're shooting
machine guns guess what guys get hit
guys go down this is even in training
guys are going down now you're gonna
carry him what are you gonna carry him
who's gonna carry him you are what are
you gonna do how you gonna carry him
you're gonna there's only one way sure
okay there's stretchers there's you can
you can bring litters and we certainly
bring litters in the field but they take
some time to set up and you've got to
get organized to make that happen what's
gonna happen initially is somebody is
gonna sling that dude on his back and by
the way that person that weighs 200
pounds has 80 pounds of gear with them
so now we're talking 280 pounds you're
gonna put that person on your back and
you're gonna walk at a high rate of
speed through this rocky terrain and
you're gonna do that for another two to
three miles to get out it's hard that
kind of training and by the way this
whole time there's no like whoo yeah
there's no hey come on there's no
there's no there's no you don't even
speak it just in silence yeah just going
everyone knows what you have to do yeah
and so that's why you got to do leg day
yeah not skip leg day cuz your legs your
legs got to carry that weight yeah going
back to the book to return to the March
about which everyone bothers themselves
to the death but we'll never reach a
conclusion unless I reveal a secret so
he's got a secret about maneuvering
troops this is this I found this
interesting some wish to march slowly
others would march fast but what about
the troops whom no one knows how to make
March fast or slowly as the desire or is
necessary and who require an officer at
every corner to make them turn like some
snails and others are running and this
is to advance this column which is
always trailing it is a comedy to see
even a battalion to commence movement so
what he's talking about is you if you're
moving with a unit and this happens with
a even happens with a platoon but it
definitely happens when you get bigger
you know a company-sized element where
you've got a hundred people that are
moving it's it's uh the caterpillar
effect right like the front moves and
then it takes a little while for people
to catch up and then when they stop
everyone bumps into him and you end up
with this this thing that's really
really hard to move yeah and this is so
this is how he says this is his big
secret shall I say at this great word
which comprises all the mystery of the
art and which which will no doubt be
seen as ridiculous have them march in
cadence that is why these musical
marches were instituted and that is why
one beats the drum it is this which no
one knows and no one has perceived with
this you can march fast or slow as you
wish the tale will not lose the distance
all your soldiers will start on the same
foot the changes of direction will be
made together with speed and grace and
the legs of your soldiers will not get
tangled up you will not be forced to
halt after each turn in order to start
off on the same foot your soldiers will
not exhaust themselves a quarter as much
as that presence now what I thought was
interesting about that is it's an
obvious answer right and now clearly
you're not going to do that
in the modern day military in the field
you're not gonna play music so guys
could march to it so you can stay in
Keynes but I think it's more important
to that sometimes we lose things we lose
[Music]
methods there in front of our face but
we don't understand why they were there
I don't say I'll tell you I was thinking
of a story I was running training and
one of my guys who was one of the
assistant platoon commanders E&T bruiser
great guy
hard to choke real long neck you know
you can make happen but you're gonna
work for it real is it well some people
you might think a long neck easy to
choke right yeah no this was his neck
was so long and he was strong to walk he
is strong long and strong neck so his
neck would like bandana guillotine that
long
so anyways we were out at this training
site and we were doing he was his it was
his platoon now he was a platoon
commander and they were coming over the
beach and meaning swimming over the
beach then you go do live-fire and it's
really so so they're doing it they're
doing iterations and he's coming up on
the beach and it's a weapons you know
you when you get to the beach your
weapons wet sandy cuz you go through the
surf and it's all jacked up and then you
try and shoot your gun it doesn't work
you got to clean it and it just a pain
and he says hey man do you have any like
suggestions on how to get my weapon
firing
once I get over the beach and I go yeah
man don't let it get wet he was kind of
you know like really and I said yeah
don't let it get wet because when you're
swimming in you've got a rucksack
but the rucksack isn't it's it's
waterproofed so it kind of floats and so
you can put your weapon on top of your
rucksack and you can kind of keep it try
there and when you're just swimming you
just keep now you're not gonna keep your
weapon completely dry it's not gonna
happen it's gonna get wet but the
attitude if you have the attitude that
you're trying to keep it dry you'll keep
it 90% more dry than you would otherwise
and most important when you come through
the beach when you come through the
waves you won't let it get the sand in
it mmm and he kind of looked at me with
you know a funny face of like are you
serious
how can you keep it dry and I said keep
it dry mm-hmm next time I'm watching him
when I'm night vision I'm watching him
and sure enough way is his weapon barely
went in the water and he got up on the
beach and boom it works guess what
that's an obvious answer but sometimes
people we know we just need to have
somebody share the obvious answer with
us so that we can execute
yeah thing is damn that's crazy I didn't
know that that marching thing like yeah
that's why you March decadence or
whatever it's like so that caterpillar
effects down the conduct that's why
there's traffic by the way yes that's
why the traffic exists because of that
little effect that's exactly true you
know one good one going in the
reaction-time you know the other funny
thing you said in here is he says go
watch people dance you see a soldier
dance all night
but he can't March for more than an hour
without being tired why is that give him
some music I don't want to say that part
but because it people started asking me
about dancing yeah yeah no talk of dance
on the podcast back to the book if the
previous war had lasted a little longer
indubitably everyone would have fought
hand-to-hand this was because the
abusive firing began to be appreciated
it causes more noise than harm and those
who depend on it are always beaten so
what do you need
I can't encapsulate a lot of stuff what
he was talking about was how everyone
was so excited to shoot their rifles and
at this time period the rifles weren't
all that accurate and so it was a bunch
of noise but they weren't always that
effective and it would be better and by
the way when you when you had to shoot
your rifle you had to stop so now
instead of charging or stopping or
loading or firing the other rank is
firing and if the other people are
moving on you well they're gonna get
close enough and they're gonna have no
now momentum and they're gonna overtake
you or they're gonna overpower you with
what with bayonets and hand-to-hand
combat so what I thought was interesting
about this is he saying hey all this
noise it's basically noise makers mmm
for all practical purposes they're noise
makers and he's saying and what I was
thinking was it speed this goes to be
this to me is very similar to people
that were yell a lot right you yell a
lot you heard someone that's loud
someone that's always talking some and
he says that people who depend on that
are always beaten mm-hmm and I thought
to myself that's a very accurate
statement very accurate statement so
don't just talk for the purpose of
talking right don't if you don't have
anything to say that's fine be quiet
don't say anything it's actually good
here he talks about the Roman legions
the Romans vanquished all nations by
their discipline no big deal they
meditated on war constant continually
and they always renounced old customs
whenever they found better
in this respect they differed from the
Gauls whom they defeated during several
centuries without the latter thinking of
correcting their errors so this is
clearly the Romans okay we know
discipline is important talk about all
the time but more important lesson here
is they always renounce to old customs
whenever they found better boom renounce
the old customs when you find better
ones this is something you need to do in
your life something need you in your
business it's something you need to do
on the mat and I'll tell you going back
to the other part sometimes there's
things in jiu-jitsu
that you find a better way and they work
for a while and then you go back to the
old way and it works because people are
expecting the new way Dean talks Dean's
say this isn't a new old move yeah yeah
yeah this is a new old move what it it
worked
ten years ago it wouldn't work five
years ago cuz everyone knew it now it'll
work again cuz everyone forgot it yeah
and that's kind of everyone forgot why
why we use cadence why we use music yeah
we forgot why we don't know how to March
now yeah yeah it's and it's essentially
the same reason why the new move will
work because people are unfamiliar you
know cuz you know you you have a certain
attack or whatever and then the more
people know about that attack the harder
it is to be successful with it and then
you find some new variation then that
not everyone knows that's I mean the
footlok game kind of was like that too
for a little bit and then after a while
all those fundamentals which were
essentially the early version of the of
the move there whatever that's still
there but we got this new unrevealed
move that's getting everyone because
they're unfamiliar it's like a surprise
kind of but they're just unfamiliar and
then now everyone gets familiar with it
and it's like whoa okay move yeah but
the real good one was that original
though do you want yeah but everyone
just got used to it yeah and then once
everyone gets used to the new one
they'll forget about the old one yeah
for sure correct and improve renounce
your old customs whenever you find
better
now he's talking a little bit about
peacetime and how you maintain your army
during peacetime he says as for the
cavalry it should never be touched -
meaning you shouldn't you shouldn't get
rid of any cavalry people the old
troopers and the old horses are the good
and the recruits of either are
absolutely useless it is a burden and it
is an expense but is indispensable in
regard to the infantry as long as there
are a few old heads you can do what you
want with the tails so a horseman is you
got the skilled horse and you've got the
skilled horse rider and he says in this
I don't know if I'll read it but that he
says he also in here takes ten years to
make a good a good cavalry man good guy
that's really good on the horse with a
really good horse takes ten years to
make them so you can't just get rid of
that person but an infantryman if you
got some good this is what I like about
it if you've got good leadership good
leadership within for treatment hey man
there's some fundamental skills you're
gonna need to learn and we'll be ready
to rock and roll
which is which is awesome good
leadership goes a long way I mean and
again you have to have it takes a lot it
takes the same amount of time to make a
good infantry leader because those are
skills that take a long time to develop
to become a leader of infantry troops
but your basic combat rifleman you can
make them pretty quick not like it's all
it's a hell of a lot easier than making
someone that can ride a horse so and
then your leadership is gonna go a long
way back to the book in attacking
infantry the two rear ranks are to lower
their Pike's in this position the Pikes
will extend from six to seven feet ahead
of the front rank the front ranks being
sheltered in such a manner will I am
sure aim with more confidence than if
they had nothing in front of them
besides this the third rank can ward off
blows and defend the first rank which
will do which it will do much better
since it is covered by the first two
ranks the second rank which is armed
with muskets can fire and defend
man in front of him in the first rank
without the latter being obliged to
stoop this avoids a serious disadvantage
which is incurred in kneeling a
dangerous movement because men who are
afraid prefer this position they cannot
be made to get up when wanted and is
always necessary to halt to kneel
according to my formation all the men
are covered each by each other with
reciprocal confidence the front presents
a forest of spears their appearances
formidable and gives confidence to your
own troops because they feel its power
so a couple interesting things there
obviously it's a cover move situation
and and and we're gonna work that out
but I thought beyond that it was
interesting that if you got us if you're
gonna take a knee well there's two
things that are happening number one you
have to stop to take a knee we're not
advancing on our knees and number two
people are afraid they want to be down
there and it's gonna be hard to get him
back up so don't even let him get down
there mmm keep that momentum going we're
looking to keep that momentum going back
to the book those who imagine that and I
think I state this every time usually
around this point in the podcast I'm
skipping a lot of the book it's just the
way it is we're not gonna read the whole
book on here you have to order it
yourself if you want to hear every
secret of sex those who imagine that the
Roman legions were composed of Romans
from Rome are very much deceived they
came from all the nations in the world
but their composition their discipline
and their methods of fighting or better
than all those other nations this is why
they conquered them all neither were
they conquered in their turn until this
discipline had to generated among the
Romans discipline will get you a long
way and lack of discipline will get you
killed
disintegrated it disintegrated talking
more about cavalry here the cavalry
should be active and mounted on horses
in nerd to fatigue
it should be encumbered with his little
baggage as possible and above all should
not make the common error of having fat
horses if they could see an enemy every
day it would only be better for this
would soon put them in a condition to
attempt anything it is certain that the
power of power of cavalry is not
understood why because of we have love
for fat horses
I had a regiment of German cavalry in
Poland with which I marched more than
1500 leagues in 18 months I maintained
that this regiment was more fit for
service at the end of this time than
another supplied with fat horses but to
reach this condition
they must be gradually accustomed to
hardship and hardened by hunts and
violent exercise this will maintain
their health and increase their
endurance likewise it will make cavalry
men of the troopers and give them a
marshal bearing so you got a train horn
I just read all that to basically say
you got a train or even want to be ready
to fight you got a train how your fight
mmm and don't get on a fat horse
apparently I have to ask my wife about
that one she knows more about horses
than me or life sure Lafe knows about
horses he's from Texas everyone from
Texas rides a horse yeah is that the
image yes when I go when I would go
overseas people for everyone in America
is basically carrying a pistol on them
at all times
that's that's the image that people have
of America I like that image for people
to have America too I mean I'm sure some
people don't like that image but yeah
you know be nice when you come here you
can want to come and visit that's cool
we welcome visitors just be nice
everyone's everyone's carrying a 45 in
their back pocket yeah yeah can you
carry a 45 in your back pocket you could
I mean would it recommend no wouldn't
recommend it you get a holster yeah yeah
yeah so back but it's more of an
expression no no it's not even
expression but if you go to another
country they think that we've just got
them in our back pocket yeah
when you carry your wallet and a 45 yes
what yes you see where I'm coming from
here yes that's how we roll Miss America
I do not back to the book I do not know
why Armour has been laid aside for the
for nothing is either so useful or
ornamental if it be considered how many
troopers perished by the sword and how
many are how many many are dangerously
wounded by random and weak shots
accident accidents against which Armour
guarantees protection one cannot avoid
acknowledging the benefits of it it is
nothing but indolence and relaxation of
discipline that caused it to be laid
aside
it is wearisome to carry a queer ass and
a trail Pike and trail a pike half a
century to use it a single day but as
soon as discipline is neglected in the
nation as soon as comfort becomes an aim
it needs no inspiration to foretell that
ruin is near the Romans conquered all
peoples by their discipline in the
measure that it became corrupted their
success decreased when the Emperor
Gration permitted the legions to quit
their cure asses and helmets because the
soldiers complained they were too heavy
all was lost the ball barians whom they
had defeated during so many centuries
vanquished them no that's all that's all
people stopped wearing their armor
because it's heavy
body armors heavy yep the helmet your
helmets heavy yeah you want that a
little tiny helmet you want the doll
let's take out the back plate of our
body or burro probably won't get shot
there No
yeah was it who was was that Jodi stop
talking about that like all I did oh
yeah though those guys going into that
they were they were going into an
operation they didn't wear their body
armor yeah because they were like dang
yeah we're not gonna happen out possibly
plus we we like maneuver
what's the thing you say yeah yeah it's
like keeping your work out and saying
well I need to rest it like recover
today yeah kind of a thing thank you
very similar yes I'll give you that one
you know I got that idea
yeah he obviously as soon as discipline
is neglected in the nation and guess
what's the same thing with your personal
life obviously back to the book the
troopers should have a goatskin bottle
like those used in hot countries instead
of a canteen or a barrel to hold liquors
in this with his linen stockings cap
accord and a few other necessities is to
be put in the bottom of a sack which
will roll up with his coat and can be
fastened with two straps behind him this
will reduce the monstrous load which is
now carried by the cavalry it is
necessary from time to time to inspect
the baggage and force the men to throw
away useless items I have frequently
done it one can hardly imagine all the
trash they carry with them year after
year the poor horse has to carry
everything it is no exaggeration to say
that I filled 20 wagons with useless
rubbish which I have found in the review
of a single regiment so people will tend
to carry a lot a lot that they don't
need and that weighs down on you I think
I've talked about this before but the
back in Berlin today we had these winter
platoons which I never did one out on
the East Coast I had these winter
platoons and you're going long distance
on cross-country skis right you know
those are mmm yeah
a long long distances and that is a very
you're basically like running a marathon
and so the guys were super anal about
the weight that they carried so like
they would you know the backpack
backpack has you know a strap that you
pull you pull the tight knit they get it
to the port where it was supposed to be
give it a little bit second thing cut
the red cut the rest off and so it's
they don't want that little extra 4
inches of nylon I'm not gonna do it they
had every piece of gear that they had
would be like that yeah the winter
warriors a team to brood
here's an interesting thing in passing
through water the horses must never be
allowed to drink a man who halts to
water his horse will stop a whole army
when this happens the officer should
hasten to the spot and instead of
fruitless reprimands an ill-timed mercy
they should instantly chastise the
offender nothing is of such importance
for the preservation of the cavalry
otherwise the affection the men they
have for their horses will have them
halting little or much and then it is
impossible for them to recover their
ranks without galloping discipline
people get that little affection further
for not just you know if I wasn't
thinking horses I was thinking about
like being on a long patrol or in the
workplace you you want your team to go
and every time you you grant that little
bit of mercy right mm-hmm am I saying be
merciless trave driver no but when you
do it you start to develop that trend
and now throws other things off and
sometimes you just gotta be hey no be
quiet and execute yeah got to go gotta
go in time of peace and in winter
quarters in time of war their horses
should be kept in conditioned by violent
exercise or runs at least three times a
week I like this idea of violent
exercise I'm gonna start doing more
violent exercising yeah that's good sort
of like violent exercising the same
severe usage is also proper for the
heavy cavalry charge at those times it
is in the field it is only in the field
that they must be managed carefully to
keep them in flesh and the squadrons
complete and strong and this is
interesting the best chance of teaching
them to stand fire is when the infantry
is practicing they should advance on the
fire and walk and be kept calm a costing
and accustoming them to go closer and
closer they should never be beaten but
stroked and encouraged encouraged in the
space of a month they will be so
accustomed to it that they will Eve
put their nose on the muzzle of the
muskets without any fright or surprise
then they are alright nevertheless they
should not be allowed to approach to
close for once they get burned you will
not be able to bring them near again
this ordeal must be reserved for the day
of battle that was good that to me
reminded me of what Jordan Peterson was
talking about anyway on the warrior kid
how you slowly inoculate people you
don't throw them into the you don't
bring them right up to the firing line
and start shooting the guns and let them
get freaked out horribly you bring them
a little distance you let them listen
from afar a moment closer and then next
thing you know they're good to go
they're standing in line what do you
call that what did Jordan Peterson call
that extinguisher yeah gradual exposure
thoroughly exposures yeah graduated
exposure therapy something cover move a
little bit of that I am convinced every
unit that is not supported is a defeated
organization infantry should always be
supported by cavalry and cavalry by
infantry cover move work together
support here's a little note back to the
book the general or commander-in-chief
of an army should have a standard to be
carried ahead of him as a mark of his
rank so he's talking about flags this is
this also has a purpose anyone searching
for him will know instantly where to
find him especially in battle and the
troops seeing the standard will know
that the general is observing them so
one thing we did and they do in the
military as they you when you're giving
your brief on how the mission is gonna
go you brief location of leadership they
say okay guys we're gonna take down
these buildings I'll be here in this
building on the top floor boom so if you
need me know where to come find me
something happens hey where's this
platoon leader gonna be yep once we get
our targets here I'm gonna come over
here I'm gonna stand on the backside
with a breach took place if you need me
that's where I'll be sorry one kind so
you know where everyone is and is he
talking about like having a skander
that's like a like a symbol it's a flag
yeah yeah that's so actual flag yeah an
actual flag so you say that wouldn't
really know we didn't do that because
isn't there like a thing
yes it's saying like hey you don't want
like I was it I want say Saving Private
Ryan it's like don't salute yeah yeah or
whatever because I want the enemy to see
where yeah yeah you did you definitely
don't want to mark your position really
like yeah well these guys are generally
and as a matter of fact and I'm trying
to think of what book we recently did
where he was talking about like yeah if
you're seen running around if you're a
radio man or you're seen running around
giving direction you're gonna get shot
yeah yeah the officer though think it
was a Vietnam I think it was I think it
was a battle I drink but yeah they're
talking about that oh yeah it definitely
was a battle I drank it was cuz when
they were leaving they said like within
within minutes the leaders had been
killed
yeah a regiment had been killed the ones
that were still with their elements so
yeah that's not something you want to do
but what we would do is brief where we
were gonna be so that everyone on the
team knew based on a terrain feature ya
know hey here's this here's this
building or here's this Knoll of this
mountain or here's this intersection
this road that's where I'll be that's
where I'm planning to be so now people
know where you are yeah makes sense and
I mean he had an additional thing there
when when he said so that you know the
generals watching there kind of thing I
guess that wouldn't really apply to
yours no no yeah it wouldn't apply
although like in the military when the
general is visiting and is a two-star
general they've raised a two-star flag
okay so I guess yeah you're right so
it'll be real circumstantial like during
a war you know that yeah yeah now he
talks about the companies and again he
calls them centuries which is basically
a company sized element of around 100
guys and he's saying that they should
have their own little symbols as well on
their own standards back to the book if
the standards are distinguished by their
different colors the actions of every
century will be conspicuous this will
create the greatest emulation because
both officers and soldiers will know
that they are seen and that their
countenance conduct and behavior are not
ignored by the rest of the army the men
as well as the officers will tell of
in the field and in garrison their
exploits will be constant the constant
subject of conversation I thought that
was kind of a cool idea you know if
you're if you're flying the flag then
people are watching you and so you
better act you better come correct
instead it represents yeah you better
represent like does it come back to the
book after the organization of military
troops military discipline is the first
matter that presents itself it is this
soul of armies hmm that has such a nice
ring to it it's the soul of the
individual as well but I suppose we'll
talk about that later
back to the book if it is not
established with wisdom and maintained
with unshakable resolution you'll have
no soldiers regiments and armies will be
only contemptible armed mobs more
dangerous to their own country than the
enemy it is a false idea that
disciplines subordination and slavish
obedience debase courage it has always
been noted that is with those armies in
which the severus discipline is enforced
that the greatest deeds are performed
many generals believe that they have
done everything as soon as they have
issued orders and that they are and they
order a great deal because they find
many abuses so he's saying there like
when a general feels like he's talking
about a bad general when a general feels
like they've done everything as soon as
they've given their order and since
that's what they do they give all kinds
of orders an order you do this in order
you do that in order to use something
else here's what he says this is a false
principle proceeding in this fashion
they will never reestablish discipline
in an army in which it has been lost or
weakened few orders are best but they
should be followed up with care
negligence should be punished without
partiality and without distinction of
rank or birth otherwise you will make
yourself hated
one can be exact and just and beloved at
the same time as feared severity must be
accompanied with kindness but this
should not have the appearance of
pretense but of goodness and this is
just a little note I thought everyone
should know whippings need not be severe
the more moderate they are the more
quickly will abuses be remedied since
all the world will join in ending them
so even when you're whipping your people
you know be a little bit more judicious
we have a this is this is good too we
have a pernicious custom in France of
always punishing with death a soldier
caught pillaging is hung the result now
what do you think the result of that
would be that he's gonna say I'm
quizzing you hang somebody if you if you
are pillaging caught pillaging you're
gonna get hung what do you think that
what do you think that happens because
of that happens to who what do you think
do to do why should we not hang people
for pillaging do you think there's a lot
of pillaging going on if you get caught
pillaging they hang you or your fellow
soldiers do you think they pillage I say
no okay you're wrong the result is that
no one arrests him because they do not
want to cause the death of a poor devil
who is only trying to live if instead we
were only turned him over to the guard
to be putting chains condemned to bread
and water for one two or three months or
put to work and in at any of the
Labour's that always have to be done in
any army and then they were sent to his
regiment before a battle or when the
general wished every would agree with
this punishment and the officers of the
patrols would arrest them by the
hundreds soon there would be no
pillaging because everyone would join in
putting it under control so the reason I
asked you that which I don't normally do
is because I thought the same thing I
was like well what's it where's he going
with us oh yeah that's obvious once you
think about it you're not gonna report
one of your guys for stealing something
if the punishment was death Brad you
know what that is that's like that's
like small picture versus big picture
small prick the small picture is like
yeah cuz because you just look at it as
your
right you get your bubble in your head
you're like I wouldn't pillage if it was
death
I wouldn't pillage and that's how you're
looking at it but no big picture is like
apply that to everyone apply it to the
whole community
exactly right if you tell on this guy
pillaging you just sentenced him to
death if you tell on him maybe you turn
him in or whatever that's what you did
good point and it's a I just remembered
somebody pointed out to me remember
rifleman Harris and it starts off with
my rifleman Harris has to execute a guy
and I said I said on the podcast hey
this guy's getting executed basically
for desertion and being drunk what I
didn't realize is if somebody sent me an
email or a social media message they
said hey the reason that guy was getting
executed was because he had taken the
money for like 16 enlistments mmm and
kept disappearing so when you do get a
signing bonus hey here's a here's
there's probably nothing but you know
here's here's ten quid or a pound
sterling or whatever here's 10 pound
sterling
oh you're joining the army cool here's
10 and then you take that money you'll
get drunk and get crazy and then you do
it again and then you it again in a
different area because I have no
internet they have no way of knowing
that this is the guy when they finally
catch him he's getting sentence to death
now do I think as you get sentence to
death either for that not really but he
was doing something more severe than
what I had mentioned on the podcast so I
just wonder while I'm thinking about
that set the record straight but the the
main point here for me is the secondary
effects right you think you're gonna
have the primary effect is oh if we do
this no one's gonna if we're gonna kill
you if you get caught pillaging no one's
gonna know who's gonna pillage anymore
yeah no actually no one's gonna report
it anymore because your punishment is -
yeah strong this is also how this is
also how and why when people think that
oh if someone's in the military the
soldiers just do what they're told wrong
the soldiers actually there's secondary
effects oh you're gonna kill the guys no
we're not gonna report it that yeah so
there's no secondary effects even though
they've been ordered to do that and
their soldiers now have discipline
they've been trained he's bragging about
discipline all time guess what they
don't Paul that order cuz the order
sucks that's what we got to remember not
just about the military but about
business too you give people dumb orders
or you give people things that don't
make sense they're not really gonna
execute it the way you'd want them to
and I'll tell you something else you
don't want them to execute that way
because if they got hundreds of people
pillaging and you now end up murdering
hundreds of on your own people you're
affecting your own army you're gonna get
deserters yeah I work in an army like
that it's the same thing with the
business start laying out severe
punishment punishment that doesn't make
sense isn't reciprocal to the crime that
was committed
I mean you pillage think about what
pillaging is I took some bread from the
store mm-hmm cool we're gonna shoot this
ahead the punishment did not fit the
crime yeah in that case all right he's
talking about where to build where to
build tactical positions and he says and
this is just the same thing he said
earlier about people but he's talking
about basically talking about terrain
now nature is infinitely stronger than
the works of man why not profit from it
meaning use a river
use a hill used used terrain to build
your defensive positions don't just used
a shovel same thing that he talked about
earlier with with human beings
now another piece many persons believe
that is advantageous to take the field
early and this is coming right back Sun
Tzu art of war be there first
yeah sacks maybe doesn't agree with that
a little bit here they are right when it
is a question of seizing an important
post otherwise it seems to me that there
is no need to hasten and that one should
remain in winter quarters longer than
usual so he goes on the talk winter
quarters means you're you're gonna go
out in the field well we're gonna go out
the field now then we're gonna be cold
wet and miserable for the next three
days while we wait for the enemy to show
up and now they show up fresh who's
gonna do better in the battle yeah so
just to think about I used to say the
military used to say all the time you
know you got to be forward leaning you
heard that expression hmm yeah it gotta
be forward leaning and I would say let's
not be so forward leaning that we're in
the leaning rest the leading rest is the
push-up position which they would leave
you in for a long periods of time a lot
of different training situations so
sometimes you get so proactive get so
leaning forward a forward
that you're in the leading rest and
you're wasting energy just trying to be
more prepared you know like you'd see
some guys warm up you do such a good
warm-up that your tires yeah you would
so far forward leaning it you're in the
leaning rest and then the other thing is
to not warm up at all now you're not
ready so you've got a fun well you get
that's an I mean leadership you gotta
find a balance between those two yeah
another good point here back to the book
it is absolutely necessary to accustom
soldiers to labor if we examine Roman
history we find we shall find that
Republic looked on ease and indolence as
the most formidable enemies the consuls
prepared their legions for battle by
rendering them indefatigable rather then
have them idle they employed them on
unnecessary works continual exercise
makes good soldiers because it qualifies
them for military duties by being
habituated to pain they insensibly
learned to despise danger the transition
from fatigue to rest innervates them
meaning weakens them they compare one
state with another and idleness that
predominate passion of mankind gains
ascendancy over them they then murmur at
every trifling inconvenience and their
souls softened and their emasculated
bodies yeah so what he's saying is
people get used to the soft ways people
get used to the easy life and if you let
them get used to it like you you when
you want to do something hard when it's
time to do something hard you're not
ready for it
every minute that Charlie's out in the
bush getting stronger every time so
every day at night I'm spending in this
hotel to Apocalypse Now every night I'm
sitting in this hotel getting softer
every night Charlie's out in the bush
getting stronger that's what he's
talking about here yeah that's what he's
talking about but now do I agree with
having people do unnecessary works no I
don't because people see right through
that and it just you're just being
stupid and taking
they're gonna see that they're gonna say
why are we doing this dig the hole fill
it back up dig the hole fill it back up
no don't do that but you know what we do
a training exercise we do training
exercise we're gonna get stronger we're
gonna get you we're gonna dig all we're
gonna put you know set it up for a
perimeter then we're gonna move to
another situation is if we have to back
away or or collapse our perimeter
because when you collapse a perimeter
you've got to fill that hole back in
otherwise in the enemy comes attack you
they use it yeah so you gotta fill that
hole back in so let's run a real drill
and by the way let's make him do a
little contest and see how fast we can
dig in and then once we get it dug in
we're gonna set up when you see how fast
we collapse it get it filled back in
we're doing it at the end of it we're
gonna give out some you know surprises
and have a beer all right that's a good
tactic by the way like to make a what
it'd be a game or if I make it yeah you
told us gamification gamification the
like if you're moving you know your
movie and how fast can I get this stuff
packed up yeah let me use it as a little
workout little metcon we got to move all
these boxes upstairs to floors or
whatever you know I'm use it as a
workout it kind of makes it more
enjoyable as well but at the same time
you get the results of a little workout
right there
here let me ask you this about that when
you said you didn't agree with the
unnecessary unnecessary works so what
about like push-ups as punishment for
example or a cat or exercise interesting
one because because I think I think like
with kids if you make burpees a
punishment they don't like it or if you
make it a reward they like them and
you're better off right yeah I agree I
do that by though yeah that's good you
make it a reward yeah Wow only the cool
people do burpees that's what it is they
see dad doing burpees dad do you know
these whatever exercise yeah only cool
people do it it I kind of push hard on
that too but it's unfair but no the
question is though in the military in
the military you're not kids
no calisthenics are definitely
punishment the military yes great it's
not until you transition out of the boot
camp service could that you get away
from that now in the SEAL Teams like
they don't you don't do calisthenics as
punishment I will say
that if you mess up like for instance
when I was running training if the guys
performed poorly they were gonna have
more down to men then this is a training
I'm talking about fake down men but
they're gonna have more men that
couldn't walk that's more men that have
to be carried that's punishment in its
own right that's punishment if you when
I was running communications course when
I was a younger enlisted seal if you
missed a communications window you had
to walk a longer distance mm-hmm if you
missed multiple you're gonna have to
walk tragic distances but that wasn't
just a natural result of you missing
missing it was did you impose that
values imposed okay yes it was imposed
and they knew it was imposed yeah okay
and and so yeah you if you miss in the
SEAL Teams if you miss the extraction
point with the boats coming to pick you
up after a dive well now you got a swim
to the nukes on the new pick a point
guess what the new pick a point isn't
closed yeah because you've compromised
now you're above the surface you need to
get away yeah and so that means you got
a swim an extra you know maybe it's an
extra hour of surface swimming with a
rig on this is not fun but uh it doesn't
sound fun yeah because you can't you're
not just you're not just having fun
right it's called turn back you know
you're laying on your back because it's
really awkward it's it's it's
comfortable to dive with our dive rig we
have a dive rig that's it's called a
rebreather any others on your chest and
it's small it's not it's not tiny closed
circuit it's closed circuit yeah look at
you look at you big time so it's a
closed circuit dive rig but when it runs
out you can't doesn't work anymore so
you have to swim and we do something
called Turtleback generally we just
basically you're laying on your back and
you're just thinning and it takes a long
time to move very far and it's not
comfortable so the punishment is in
training if you miss your extraction
point
that's fine you just gotta swim to the
alternate extraction point the alternate
extraction point is not gonna be close
by because you screwed up yeah
same thing with if you miss your
helicopter extraction because you took
too long on target and you got bogged
it took you long time to move all these
down people that's I mean it happens we
understand that but now you have to walk
to the secondary extraction point which
happens to be six kilometers up a hill
yeah see but that's tea to me and this
is me thinking whatever 10 seconds to
but that seems like that makes perfect
sense in fact that seems like a cool
little strategy because in real life
that's how it works yes the bus you ride
the bus to school you miss the bus
you're walking to school or be riding
your bike whatever it's kind of that
thing that's the best how life deals it
to you a lot of the time like these
types of things there what you're saying
yeah yeah but let's say hey you you know
your shoes aren't shined or whatever I
don't know your aren't shine give me 50
pushups oh they don't do it in the SEAL
Teams they definitely do it in the army
they definitely doing the Rangers
Rangers that they're dropping down all
the time right and but no we don't do
that so that's a question though dee do
you agree with that or or even think
about that nest I don't think about that
kind of stuff yeah I think being why I
would say that I that I would not do it
when I was in a military leadership
position just because I would rather I
don't know yeah it's weird it feels like
it like just like you're okay makes
sense when I know that the army runs it
that way it makes sense and by the way
when the army does it and I shouldn't
even say anything else about the way the
army does it because I'm not I don't
know exactly how they implement that
strategy so the next time we have Tim
Kennedy on we'll get him to give us a
full debrief on that and we'll get
another another Ranger on here to give
us a full debrief on that here's
something so I was watching the show and
this random show me my wife before we
were married when we were just dating
whatever we'd watch these random shows
and it was a kind of like a reality show
kinda like a competition show but it was
I think army like in a you grab regular
people put a man army scenario you give
them like missions and it's like because
they have a ranger they have a best
ranger every year they have a best
Ranger competition which is a really
hardcore competition yeah was it's you
know it's a lot like the FTX a lot like
that but it's a whole like you know
you're there for like a month or writer
and same but a lot of drill sergeant
type situations dropping in me 2050
whatever right so heels towards the end
of the season or whatever and this girl
was like she was like dang look how
strong and like muscular my arms are now
this boom just from all the push-ups we
had to do and stuff like that just by
happenstance sure she was getting
punished sure she was learning to you
know follow directions more meticulously
and all the stuff that you learned from
you know the whole you know orders
versus punishment situation but as kind
of a byproduct if you will she has some
physical strength now you know yeah
wonder if that has something to do with
you're definitely you're definitely
making people stronger there's no doubt
about it yeah that's all that's all
positive for sure yeah yeah this there's
no doubt you the great bright byproduct
of of calisthenics as punishment is you
get stronger yeah in but like in the in
the seals it's weird it's weird it's not
a thing yeah it's not a thing okay
you're gonna drop down and give me 50
like that literally I never saw that
happen a single mmm it might have
happened with new guys sometimes but
your case your if a new guy that you're
not getting through them okay guess what
but even with new guys if you really
want to get through got what you want
them to be good at as tactics not
push-ups people in regimes you're
supposed to do push-ups on your own man
yeah that's the anyway seems like we're
not in here to teach you how to do
push-ups like you need to you need to be
in shape but it seems like yeah better
things to do exist yes what I was gonna
say but here but at the same time you
can't help but wonder maybe that's just
like that's a certain way of looking at
it which is good it seems obvious seems
effective to me but what if there's
something like that you know like
something from back in the day some
old-school fundamental principle that
that's kind of why you do it the super
maybe maybe that's why in the teams they
don't do it because they want you to be
self-disciplined yeah not like specific
yeah not not self not disciplined by the
group but imposed but yeah you don't
impose discipline so well regardless I
think that you should train hard because
you don't want to have your soul get
softened inside of your emasculating
body
that just sounds like something I don't
want to be a part of it's all keep
training back to the book there is more
skill in one might think in then my then
one might think in making poor
dispositions intentionally but one must
be able to change them into good ones in
an instant so he's talking about how you
set yourself up in a bad position only
to let the enemy try and maneuver all
that but you're waiting for him it's
you're ready and do something you change
your position and do something good like
in jiu-jitsu when you let someone set up
a triangle but you're just trying to
pass their guard gotcha yeah
nothing is more disconcerting to the
enemy he is counted on a certain thing
has disposed himself accordingly and at
the instant of attacking it has changed
so this is this is pretty cool right
this is a good thing to remember
I like weight talk boss is psychological
effect that it has on the enemy so the
enemy sees something they expect
something they want something to go a
certain way so they arrange themselves
for it and then right when they're
getting ready to execute they realize it
wasn't what they thought and he says
there's nothing more disconcerting and
I'd say that's true the person - mmm you
know with with the unexpected is what
disturbs people especially you see this
all-time in MMA where a guy gets close
to a submission and then he think other
guy gets out yeah and he expended some
Jenners you can see the you can see the
the the moral draining from their face
when it's bad like he's bad sometimes do
you know he goes on I repeat nothing
confuses him so greatly and leads him
into more serious faults if he does not
change his disposition he will be
defeated and if he changes them in the
presence of the enemy he will still be
defeated human spirit cannot meet it I'm
trying to think of how that affects
someone's psyche oh yeah it affects it
it definitely affects you
psychologically like you throw the you
you think I get this person the triangle
you put it on
and almost sunroom you realize it's not
just that you missed the triangle it's
so you realize that you got played you
played right and that doesn't feel good
and I can definitely hurt your morale
yeah yeah big time that's a little
different than just missing the move
when you realize you've got set up
seeing that it messes up your whole game
so okay so you roll with stilts right
yeah okay so that's that's it I don't
want to say that's his whole game but
that's his game right there so like if
you go you know side control or mound or
whatever he has dangerous movie once you
turn one yet yes exactly right so it's
like and every once in a while you get
rolling with him like kind of hard it'll
seem like he's trying to defend them out
but he's really letting you think that
you got the mouse right you know cuz
even if you're like if someone's letting
you mount you know they're letting you
mouth yeah and if they're gonna spring
some sort of a trap is gonna be more
obvious if they're letting you do it but
you get them where he kinda lets you do
it to the point where you don't realize
he's a lady yeah you just got and then
again after a while he keeps doing stuff
like that to your like fraud I don't
even really want to do anything to him
because he's just gonna some it's this
is just a bunch of traps right now so it
messes up your whole game you can't do
anything yeah like on your own accord
though it's not like he's preventing you
from doing anything yeah it's like
you're preventing yourself now that's a
that's a situation you need to deal with
I figured out I didn't figure it out I
figured out a method to deal with just
that whole scenario with him by the way
and he even like asked me afterwards so
I was like oh let's I was going hard and
I was you know how you get real like
weary like okay I know he's gonna
something I saw was real uneventful so
like hey let's go roll again and then I
just loosened up and basically allowed
him to spring whatever trap he wants and
he didn't he did all this stuff and he
was like hey you were rolling a lot
lighter in that time I was like no bruh
I'm just trying to I'm trying to turn on
the lights to all your traps that you
said you know so it's kind of like that
thing just comes with like the type of
training like you can't regard the
training as a competition yeah you know
you'd be like the wise you were not
learning anything yeah but man you know
in a war battle or in a competition
scenario it's like don't make a you a
big day I'm trying to think if I ever
got played like that on the battle
you know sometimes we'd hit a target mmm
it was real obvious that you know we had
been I wouldn't say set up but like
there's no one there like clearly the
information that we got was wrong and
you'd be kind of like you know be like
man that wasn't good yeah and really on
a real rudimentary level it that's what
an AED is you know it's like you they
want to make it look like a trash can or
a regular there's something you have to
address or something like that you know
some a place where you have to go anyway
the road I don't know what on a real
simple level that's kind of what that is
so now you're like shoo now we got to be
weary of everyday things normal protocol
we got to be weary yes
yeah that's a that's a digger on the
psychology for sure yeah back to the
book I do not care for either one oh
sorry it says lines and entrenchment so
he's talking about lines and
entrenchments meaning defensive
positions I do not care for either the
one or the other of these works when I
hear talk of lines I always think I am
hearing of talk of the walls of China
the good ones are those that Nature has
made and the good entrenchments are good
dispositions and brave soldiers again
just capitalizing on nature and saying
that brave soldiers are more important
than your position man always fears the
consequences of danger more than danger
itself totally true when and I'll tell
you what's equally or you could throw
there is the the anticipation of danger
is probably the worst thing there I see
this I see a lot of kids on the
wrestling mat right now cuz it's
wrestling season and you can see the
kids get nervous before they get on the
map and then once to get on the mat
they're in the game yeah and now you're
now you're doing your job but the
anticipation of what could happen yeah
people crazy when is that like you know
cuz you got it you felt that before
we're you know back today when we were
competing
yeah like p.m. jiu-jitsu tournaments the
war especially back actually you're one
year last calm
was my first competition by the way yeah
where was that in LA it was called like
the Pan Am's of submission grappling it
wasn't the Pan Am's Pan Am's it was like
I think like submission grappling it was
new how did I do
I don't know yeah I remember seeing all
the pictures because one of the is funny
wanted like tournament it was tournament
yeah so remember alicia photos remember
Nana who ran a who had the tournament I
have no idea I didn't even know there
was tournaments and I saw one or branded
the time was like yeah the term I was
like oh we can have tournaments I was
like boom so I just jumped on it real
quick what was the iconic photo I say
its iconic because it's a kind of a
strong word
yeah very sure it's not iconic at all
actually but it's cam so I'm Liam I have
this guy his name is Jim you'll probably
know Jim yeah I have him in a it's not
an American it's a straight arm lock and
I wound up tapping him out and Alicia
photos so that was the photographer at
that time I mean I had a really good
picture of it it was such a good picture
he was on the front of her website the
picture right that's why I call it
iconic photo everyone knows that photo
everyone they probably do if they're
competing back at the day if they know
photos anyway no full-on like novice
division right I was like I'd been
trying for two months twice a week by
the way for two months from now um still
just dominating out there actually lost
I lost my first match took third
nonetheless doesn't matter um so I know
that you did it because when I was
looking through the pictures it was you
compete I think you're competing against
like so could you or somebody I think
but I remember against so could you yeah
well it was maybe I don't know some
other black guy but I don't know I
remember it was you because I remember
like you I'll have to check that out
nonetheless have to explore that but oh
yeah waiting for the match is like
that's the nerve round part yeah like
rolling even when you step on the match
and you see the guy in front of you
getting red that's not nerve-wracking at
all that's like everyday you see that
there was a iconic picture of sorry
this is pretty iconic and it was going
against one of the Gracie's kids so it
was Henner or pingu's Halleck was a
holiday yeah and he's double like him
you know yes
Sarge's got like this savage double leg
which Sarge has a savage double work
it's another thing when I see these by
the way talking about Brian sergeant one
of my buddies who has a dude in school
in Connecticut
it's called jiu-jitsu life but he has
he's a good wrestler but when I see
these kids and he he wrestled Poway high
school which is a one of the best
wrestling high schools maybe in the
country I mean it's definitely
incredible program and he went there and
wrestled there and I see occasionally
I'll see you kids that just has Sarge's
attitude and I saw one of this last
tournament this kid was just all over
hit and I mean it looked it didn't look
fair I mean he was just murdering this
kid from Poway was getting after it's
pretty awesome to watch and you could
see just boom boom boom his hitting the
devil's but it reminded me of the iconic
picture of Sarge
oh there's a picture so yeah there's a
picture of Sargent they put him up date
was that it was it was one of those
pictures that was so good that they put
it like on the cover say I think I don't
know if it was that one if it happened
later in the match he was double liking
him out of bounds like he has in the
tables so yeah you gotta watch out for
sergeant double legs if you put you own
you I ask quick and he you want to start
doing hard to submit so like you just
got taken down that's two points and now
what are you gonna do cuz you can't
sweep Sarge right corn I mean if I can
but it's hard yeah you only have a few
minutes and it's hard to submit oh but
you got back your feet cool you just got
taken out yeah yeah that's the rub with
real good judo guys or wrestler guys
that's the rub what's the rub oh how do
you solve that problem yeah
become a better Russell typically that's
not it yeah because I roan Woodley tyron
woodley fought Demian Maia and Damien
Damien is an incredible jiu-jitsu player
and he couldn't get tiring down to the
mat and every time he shot I would hit
my son and because every time every time
Damien shot he would Tyron would just
stuff the shot and I'd hit my son and go
that's why you wrestle that's where you
wrestle boy yes you gonna be able to
take people down yeah and then once you
get to the ground if you have the
jiu-jitsu
well now you got problems yeah cuz Tyron
didn't want to go to the ground with
Damien no because that would have been
very problematic for him yeah but tyron
woodley is a wrestler oh you know was
that you who said there's a difference
between someone who can wrestle versus a
wrestler yes yes and that's why I say
that's not the problem
all right that's why I say that's not
the solution if you're a wrestler always
taking you down and the solution is to
get better wrestling the solution
because you you want to get better at
something that this guy is probably
getting better and this is just chances
are I'm not saying it's an absolute but
he's probably a getting better be
already super good at it so it's like
the solution is they just chase
something that's 12 years ahead of you
yeah he's eight years ahead of you in
wrestling no yeah so that's not the
solution I don't know I'm not saying
don't wrestle well I think I'll tell you
what this is what I think the solution
is off the top of my head you learned
enough wrestling and then you figure out
how to incorporate your dude into the
wrestling so that and I say this all
time and Dean will tell you the same
thing Dean will a Dean will hesitate to
shoot on me because he knows there's
significant threats there he'll shoot
all day on a good wrestler because he
doesn't care what happens they're not
gonna they're not gonna catch him most
likely I mean obviously jujitsu
wrestlers can happen but and I feel the
same way I'll shoot I'll shoot all day
on the on a good wrestler cuz I don't
care they're not gonna catch me anything
and if they do often be able to do the
proper defense and escape it but Dean no
like no that's a real problem
yeah same with Andy you shoot on a knee
you're you know it's like okay that
could be problematic yeah
not even just pay for you can lose right
there yeah yeah Annie and I having a
problem whoever shoots Lou whoever
shoots loses because we're both have
good anti wrestling so yeah that's it
that's the problem that's the solution
right there you got to figure out that
the counter that kryptonite to the
wrestling right in what in whatever way
cuz that's not just do that that's not
how it is it's but that's the direction
that's a solution yeah there's there's
problems with that well there's not
problems that one of the easiest ways is
to be very I guess this is a problem is
to be very non aggressive because if all
you're trying to do is avoid getting
taken down you already are a lot harder
to take down then if you're like if I go
in and start trying to take down a
wrestler they're gonna put me on my ass
because I'm trying to take them they
know their counters that much better
their time is that much better they hit
the switch balls on them but I'm down
yeah you know but if I'm just trying to
avoid you it's the same thing with
someone that's really good striker if
you're just if your goal is to if you
start striking with a striker that's
better than you you are more likely to
get knocked out you're more leading like
to get hit because you're playing there
that's the point you're playing their
game yeah and you don't want to play
their game
now what sucks about that and it even
happened the tyron woodley fight it was
a boring fight because it was shots
getting stuffed stand up just as much as
some striking shots getting stuff to
stand up glady striking shots getting
stuff that's what the fight was it was a
very boring fight because his goal is to
not get taken down and he's a wrestler
so he had the capability of doing it and
now was that I'll tell you what it did
what you do for a wrestling situation is
one of those simple it's not easy at all
but simple you find a way to get to the
back from the bottle oh yeah that's
great yeah you find a way to submit one
to submit them that's great to know know
what get to the right because dip it and
under lava get told me them to their
back no get on their back so for sure it
on their back under Hughes he told me
this when he was gonna fight Chael
Sonnen mmm-hmm from metamoris and he was
like he's like yeah it's interesting
fighting wrestlers who
like they can provide like that I'm
totally paraphrasing they can provide
these really hard situations for you in
jujitsu for many reasons they're super
hard hard people to fight but if you can
figure it out you got to figure out ways
we're wrestling provides weaknesses in
an energy Jitsu scenario yeah and then
if you watch the match sure enough like
he was shell Sonia was really good at
stuffing stuffing stuffing stuffing and
then you could see gulp I was like just
slowly and then he got to the back and I
used to coach Dean with the same idea of
you know if he was going against a good
wrestler I'd say use your jujitsu if
he's gonna get so good
jujitsu got to use your wrestling thing
Dean would have a tendency because of
his personality to want to go against
them in their strength so he tried out
wrestle wrestlers he tried how did you
do out jiu-jitsu guys he would he would
that's his natural tendency would be to
go at people's strengths and I'd have to
like say no do jujitsu against this guy
and then he'd do it and get what we
needed to get mmm all right back to the
book when one is obliged to defend
entrenchments one should post all the
battalions directly behind the parapet
because if once the enemy sets foot upon
that those in the rear will think of
nothing but to save themselves this is
because of the consternation in men when
something happens that they have not
expected again concentration is like
shock
so he's again emphasizing the fact that
when people aren't expecting something
it is a BISM pager down or form it's a
major downer it interrupts what's
happening yeah and that's why you gotta
think of contingencies that's one of the
biggest things one of the best things
about thinking about contingencies it's
just that you're aware of it's gonna
happen that you've thought about it for
a half a second big time that makes you
so much better off getting caught
complete getting caught completely
off-guard I mean this happens in jujitsu
the thing that you get caught with is
the thing that you didn't see coming
yeah that's that's the thing that
catches you the thing that's surprising
you and your like how that happened yeah
it surprised you that's what you get
caught with even like in your house like
that's the one I think of a lot where
you know when you're in your house and
and if you think of like what if there's
someone in here
oh yeah right now yeah you're not even
necessarily of how scary that would be
necessarily but it's like okay what if
there's someone in here at least I'm
ready for the fact that someone's in
here my daughter my eight-year-old
daughter will try and scare me yeah yeah
yeah
and she'll hide somewhere and if I don't
expect it I get started again yes yeah
that's you and then and then what I do
is I just you know you're talking about
punishments know what I thought Ronis
myself oh yeah yeah that's good so she
scared me twice last year like that
actually made me a little bit startled
she tried ninety eight times ninety six
of them were ineffective but I I
punished myself yeah well or bercy's
Burpee school and then but I really
enjoy scaring people sure a lot I don't
know why I find it very entertaining and
funny and satisfying so I do when I
scare people it like makes them cry yeah
we all have you scare them do you do
they like the loud noise one or do you
everything yeah you know because a lot
of times the loud noise isn't the scary
thing right and sometimes the scratching
at the window is the dread yeah
sometimes you think you're home alone
you think your dad's gone then all of a
sudden there's like scratching at the
window and there's a noise of the door
opening and you start calling out for
your dad but he doesn't answer and
there's more scratching at the window
and then all of a sudden there's someone
with a mask on that comes in yeah you
can do that that's thing yeah that's a
violation you can't do that no man I do
do that yeah yeah yeah so anyways that's
that back to the book he said well let
me catch us up to where we're talking
about the shock that happens when people
don't expect something back to the book
this is a general rule in war and
decides all battles and all actions it
comes from the human heart and is what
induced me to compose this work I do not
believe that anyone yet has attempted to
find their
find they're the reasons for the poor
success of armies thus when you have
stationed your troops behind a pair of
foot they hope by their fire to prevent
the enemy from passing the ditch and
mounting it
if this happens in spite of the fire
they give themselves up for lost lose
their heads and fly they'll be much
better to post a single rank they're
armed with Pike's whose business will be
to push the assailant back as fast as
they attempt them out and certainly they
will execute this duty because is what
they expect and what they prepared for
if with this you post infantry formed
according to my method in two centuries
at a distance of thirty paces from the
entrenchment these troops will see that
they are placed there to charge the
enemy as fast as he enters and attempts
to form they will not be astonished to
see the enemy enter because they expect
it and will charge
vigorously instead if instead they had
been placed on the parapet they would
have fled that is how a trifle changes
everything in war and how human
weaknesses cannot be managed except by
allowing for them that's that's heavy
right there yeah human weaknesses cannot
be managed you have to allow for them
think about that ya think you know you
have to do that all time as a leader you
have to well you have to try and do it
as leader because if you don't try and
manage these weaknesses and you you you
don't allow for them then they're gonna
they're gonna Jam you up as you would
say yeah so you got somebody with a big
ego you you got a put you gotta put them
in a situation where that egos gonna
flourish and not be offended in and when
it does get offended you got to allow
for that and how you're gonna adapt to
it yeah it's like expecting perfection
you know you know like if you expect
perfection yeah well you're gonna be let
down a bunch yeah is what I'm saying so
if you allow for imperfection you can
you can just manage better so there's
two major points you know number one if
you set people up so that what makes
what they expect to happen happens
they're gonna have a better chance of
achieving what it is you want them to
achieve because if these guys are in the
parapet all of a sudden they
run upon and they're surprised by it and
their mission was defend the parapet
well now they're there getting overrun
whereas if you say no once the parapet
gets taken you attack now they're they
know the parapets and it's not gonna be
surprised them they expect it to happen
and then when they they get the
opportunity they're gonna get in there
and get after it but man allowing the
the manage managing human weakness only
the only way you can do this by allowing
for it at least some measure of it good
good lesson learned that's something you
can think about as you lead people you
can think about hey man this is a little
weakness here and if I don't know how
for that it'll give that some room and I
count on you know Flynn Flynn from
echelon front newest member of national
in front but he just wrote an article
about a guy he was stationed on a ship
before he got to the teams and he was
saying this guy had been late for work
and but he was trying to bring the guy
along he had a lot of potential blah
blah blah anyways they go to actually do
a important training with their weapons
on the ship that they were on and the
guy missed the ship leaving port and he
says you know I should have fired the
guy before this and now I'm out here I
don't have this primary guy and he let
down me and let down the ship and
everything like that but he didn't
account for human weakness he you know
he thought that he could bring this guy
along but he just you know it's one of
those things if you don't allow for that
human weakness in there you might be you
might be getting left high and dry which
is not good that's only made that thing
on the Echelon front webpage which is
called the platoon not yeah and we're
just like writing little I guess it
could be referred to as a blog it's not
really a blog because a blog to me seems
very you know just say where's it right
whatever blog II yeah so this is this is
some little I guess you might want to
call them articles yeah and there's
little lesson yeah yeah yeah yeah I like
to enjoy and the reason we call the
platoon hunt is because that's where you
and talk shop I guess we talk about
other things but when you get back from
a training op because when you're
overseas you you still have a platoon up
but it's not V platoon I guess it is but
anyways yeah even there so when you get
back to an operation you come in your
debrief and you you get done with the
official debrief but then you go into
the platoon hood yeah you should do this
so yeah so that's one of those he as a
young Surface Warfare Officer in the
Navy didn't allow for the human weakness
of this young sailor and in Austin going
back to the book the Greeks were very
skillful in the art of war and well
disciplined but they're large phalanx
was never able to contend with the small
bodies of Romans disposed in this
formation now he goes on to there's a
guy named polybius and he goes on to
quote a huge chunk of text from Polybius
previous was a greek historian and polly
biasts actually talked about why the
roman armies could defeat the Phalanx
and pretty interesting so here's what he
said it is easy to demonstrate by many
reasons that while the Phalanx retains
its proper form and full power of action
no force is able to stand against it in
front or in support of the violent
attack so while the Phalanx is in order
you're not going to be able to defeat it
so the Phalanx is a military formation
and he talks a little bit about what
it's made up of here when the ranks are
closed in order to engage each soldier
as he stands with his arms occupies a
space of three feet the spears in their
ancient form or 17 cubits long a cubit
is about 18 inches but for the sake of
rendering them more commodious and
actions they have since been reduced to
14 of these four cubits are contained
between the part which the soldier
grasps in his hands and the lower end of
the spear behind which serves as a
counter poised to the part that is
extended before
and when and the length of this last
part from the body of the soldier when
the spear is pushed forwards with both
hands against the enemy is in
consequence ten cubic cubits from hence
it follows that when the phalanx is
closed in its proper form
every soldier pressed within the
necessary distance with respect to the
man that is before him and on his side
the spears of the fifth-ranked are
extended to the length of two cubits and
those of the second third and fourth to
is still greater length beyond the
formal strength it is manifest manifest
then that several Spears differing each
other in the length of two cubits are
extended before every man in the
foremost rank and when it is considered
like why is that the phalanx is formed
by 16 in depth it will be easy to
conceive what must be the weight and
violence of the entire body and how
great the force of its attack so you got
guys 16 people deep 16 people deep and
they've got these Spears and they adjust
the spears depending on where you are in
the rank so the guy that's five ranks
back still has a little bit of his spear
sticking out and by the way if one of
those guys goes down there's another
fourteen people they're ready to take
his place
so the Phalanx was locked together the
shield's protecting the person to your
left and it's like a porcupine of death
locked together you know and obviously
the the Greeks were hardcore warriors
and this is what they used and they used
to crush people with this phalanx crush
them Spears and shields that's all you
see hmm now Polybius talks about what
the Romans did and what their setup was
back to the book to each of the Roman
soldiers as he stands in arms is a lot
of the same space of three feet but as
every soldier in time of action is
constantly in motion being forced to
shift this shield continuously so that
he may cover any part of his body
against which a stroke is
aimed and to vary the position of his
sword so as to either push or to make a
falling stroke there must be also a
distance of three feet the least that
can be allowed for performing these
motions with advantage between each
soldier and the man that stands next to
him both on his side and behind him so
the Romans are in the same similar
position but they're moving individually
inside these little positions so not
working together they're they're more
mobile it will be easy therefore to
conceive that while the Phalanx retains
its proper position and strengths no
troops as I have before observed canna
support the attack of it in front so if
you're gonna get the Phalanx you're
gonna lose if you're going front to what
cause then is a described that the Roman
armies are victorious and those defeated
that employed the Phalanx so how is it
that the Romans were able to beat the
Phalanx this is the cause in war the
times and places of action are various
and indefinite but there is only one
time and place one fixed and determined
manner of action that is suited to the
Phalanx in the case of a general action
if an enemy be forced to encounter with
the Phalanx in the very time and place
which the latter requires it is probable
in the highest degree that the Phalanx
must obtain victory so if you fight the
Phalanx where the Phalanx wants you to
fight it meaning on a big open area mmm
you're gonna lose but if it is possible
to avoid an engagement in such
circumstances and it is indeed easy to
do it there is nothing to be dreaded
from this order of battle and here's
where it gets to the nitty-gritty it is
well known and an acknowledged truth
that the Phalanx requires a ground that
is plain and naked and free from
obstacles of every kind such as trenches
breaks and browse of hills or the
channels of rivers and that any of these
are sufficient to impede it and to
dissolve it the unto dissolve the order
in which it was formed he
the enemy coming down up down on it
should lead their army through the
country plundering the cities and
ravaging the lands of what use then will
be the Phalanx so all you have to do is
get them on some rough terrain you get
them on some rough terrain and that
phalanx I mean it's it's hard to March
already we know that but now we're
marching against weird terrain and the
guy in front of you trips and falls wolf
heat what does he hit he hits a rock and
how that makes this guy fall and all of
a sudden we got a big disaster on our
hands back to the book when the Romans
attacked the Phalanx in the front they
never employ all their forces so as to
make their line equal to that of the
enemy but lead on only a part of their
troops and the rest they keep in reserve
now whether the troops the Phalanx break
the line that is opposed to them or
whether they are broken themselves the
formation peculiar to the Phalanx is
alike dissolved so even if they win that
initial onslaught even if the Phalanx
wins that the Phalanx is out of order
if they pursue the fugitive or if on the
other hand they retreat and are pursued
in either case they are separated from
the rest of their own body and thus
there is left some space which the
reserve of the Roman army takes care to
seize and then charges the remaining
part of the Phalanx but the charge is
not made against the front but in the
flank or the rear since it is easy then
to avoid the conditions that are
favorable to the Phalanx and since those
on the contrary that are disadvantageous
to it can never be avoided it is certain
that this difference alone must carry
with it a decisive weight in time of
action so let them get a little bit
disrupted once they're disrupted flank
them hmm the troops of the Phalanx lose
all their strength when they engage in
separate companies or man-on-man the
Roman order on the contrary is never
attended even on such occasions with any
disadvantage among the Romans every
single soldier when he is once armed and
ready for service is alike fitted and
engaged fitted to engage in any time or
place on any appearance of the enemy and
preserves that always the
same power and the same capacity in
action whether in separate companies or
man-to-man so big destructive element in
front of you don't go head on head with
it we've learned this over and over
again you might want to distract it sure
but then you hit them from the flank and
don't face people on their best category
right don't wrestle against the wrestler
don't do jujitsu against the jiu-jitsu
guy don't box against the boxer don't go
at them or and don't do it where they
want to do it and that's real important
disrupting the Phalanx mm-hmm now he
talks about attacking entrenchments
which again these are defensive
positions when an end trench man is to
be attacked an attempt should be made to
extend the lines as much as possible
makes sense right I just don't want to I
want to let make the person think that
were going to attack him on the whole
the whole line that he's got this will
make the enemy fearful everywhere so
that he will not withdraw troops from
any point to reinforce that which you
intend to attack even after he discovers
it this makes many of his troops useless
in this was d-day so what we did on
d-day you know they did those massive
deception operations the Brits the
Americans had built those fake tanks and
fake planes and put them all there they
were inflatable you've seen that stuff
right
everything that oh yeah the Americans
and the Brits when we were trying to to
confuse Hitler about where we were going
to attack d-day they made these they
made like fake airplanes and fake tanks
and they put him in different locations
that indicated that we'd probably attack
in this spot instead of that spot and it
all works and and so he had to defend
the whole line he actually defended
those areas where they thought the
attack was coming more than they
defended the area or d-day was huh
little deception operation
back to the book too much attention
cannot be paid to spies and guides they
are like eyes and are equally necessary
to a general general he is too much
money cannot be spent to get good ones
these men should be chosen in the
country where the war is being fought
they should be intelligent cunning and
discreet spies the commanding general I
have formed a picture of a commanding
general which is not shammiracle
I have seen such men the first qualities
the first of all qualities is courage
without this the others are of little
value since they cannot be used the
second is intelligence which must be
strong and fertile in expedience the
third is health he should possess a
talent for sudden and appropriate
improvisation that's a good that's they
don't expect that a talent for sudden
and appropriate improve it improvisation
if I didn't make this clear enough he's
kind of going through the
characteristics that he believes a good
commanding general should have he should
be able to penetrate the minds of other
men while remaining impenetrable himself
he should be endowed with a capacity of
being prepared for everything with the
active with activity accompanied by
judgment with the skill to make proper
decision on all occasions and with
exactness of discernment good lists he
should have a good disposition free from
from Caprice and be a stranger to hatred
and Caprice is like you're just gonna
change your mind all the time hmm he
should punish without mercy especially
those who are dearest to him but never
from anger because remember earlier he
was talking about be yeah kind of chill
with it with the lashings but he says
you should punish without mercy
especially those who are D
to you and I think that goes to what he
was saying about troops hey you're gonna
draft people you got to make sure you
draft the the rich people too and I
think he's saying you got to treat
people fairly right even when you're
even when it's a boys he should always
be grieved when he is forced to execute
the military rules and should have the
example of Meneely Asst constantly
before his eyes and manliest action
actually manliest he was like a Roman
hero during during the Garlic siege and
he but beyond that he was sort of like a
I'm gonna call my human rights advocate
but maybe that's too strong but anyways
he ended up getting a crucified throne
from him from from a great height and
killed as execution but he's sort of
seen as a guy that stood up he almost
was in like an Alamo scenario hmm
like in Texas when that when they when
they stood and were killed he was in one
of those situations but he wasn't killed
during that galaxy Jerome anyways back
to the book he should discard the idea
that is he who punishes and should
persuade himself and others that he only
administers the military laws with these
qualities he will be loved he will be
feared and without doubt obeyed the
functions of a general are infinite he
must know how to subsist his army and
how to husband it how to place it so
that it will not be forced upon to fight
except when he chooses how to form his
troops in an infinity of different
infinity of different dispositions how
to profit from that favourable moment
which occurs in all battles and which
decides their success all these things
are of immense importance and are as
varied as the situations and
dispositions which produce them in order
to see all these things the general
should be occupied with nothing else the
day of the battle
the inspection of the terrain and the
disposition of his troops should be
prompt like the flight of an eagle this
done his orders should be short and
simple as for instance the first line of
attack the first line will attack and
the second will be in support boom
that's it keep it simple the generals
under his command must be incompetent
indeed if they do not know how to
execute this order and to perform the
proper maneuvers with their respective
divisions thus the commander-in-chief
will not be forced to occupy himself
with it
nor be embarrassed with the details for
if he attempts to be a battle sergeant
and be everywhere himself he will
resemble the fly in the fable that
thought he was driving the coach thus on
the day of the battle I should want the
general to do nothing his observations
will be better for his judgement will be
more sane and he will be in a better
state to profit from the situations in
which the enemy finds himself during the
engagement and when he sees an occasion
he should unleash his energies hasten to
the critical point at top speed seize
the first troops available advance them
rapidly and lead them in person these
are the strokes that decide battles and
gain victories the important thing is to
see the opportunity and know how to use
it so what are you saying there's got to
be detached mmm he's saying you got to
be detached and then you got to stay
back you got to look around now he also
says once you see the critical moment
you got to get up in there and make it
happen but he's saying you definitely
can't get laid down on the weeds you
can't be the sergeant that's trying to
do everything back to the book many
commanding generals only spend their
time on the day of the battle in making
their troops march in a straight line in
seeing that they keep their proper
distances in answering questions which
their aides-de-camp come to ask in
sending them hither and thither and in
running about incessantly themselves in
short they try to do everything and as a
result do nothing
so this is a great this is just you're
in a leadership position you try and do
everything yourself you're not gonna do
anything at all then it's the same
that's the same thing as prioritizing XQ
if you try and solve all the problems
that are happening at the same time
you're not gonna solve any of those
problems they appear to me like men with
their heads turned who no longer see
anything and who are only able to do
what they have done all their lives
which is to conduct troops methodically
under their orders uh under the orders
of a commander how does this happen
it is because very few men occupy
themselves with the higher problems of
war they pass their lives drilling
troops and believe that this is the only
branch of the military act when they
arrive at the command of armies they are
totally ignorant and in default of
knowing what should be done they do what
they know that is so classic it's so
classic when people don't know they
don't understand something they do what
they know how to do they always default
into what they know how to do their
minds are closed one of the branches of
the art of war that is to say drill and
the method of fighting is methodical the
other is intellectual for the conduct of
the latter it is essential that ordinary
ordinary men should not be chosen unless
a man is born with a talent for war he
will never be other than a mediocre
general it is the same with all talents
in painting or music or in poetry the
talent must be inherent for excellence
all sublime arts are alike in this
respect that is why we see so few
outstanding men in science centuries
pass without producing one application
rectifies ideas but does not furnish a
soul for that is the work of nature you
know I just answered a question on
Twitter I think it was and I basically
said
you know you can't do whatever you want
just because you believe in it and you
have hard work and discipline like but
that doesn't mean you can do whatever
you want like as a career or something
yeah like and I always use the example
like I couldn't be an Olympic let's say
an Olympic weightlifter or in fact I
don't know that there's any Olympic
sport that I would be that I have the
genetic makeup to be able to to be able
to compete at the Olympic level of
course we could go back and maybe that's
possible from a child but I don't feel
like it but even right now
you know if you take that to the extreme
that means hey you know what if I have
the focus now if I have the discipline I
can become an Olympic wrestler now high
jumper Olympic high jumper right how's
that vert looking so he's here I'm
saying now my opinion is that is not
true and some people are not going to
achieve certain things that they may
want to achieve no matter how hard they
want to do it and I you know most people
like how that's realistic
some people like no you can believe you
believe it you can achieve it it's like
if I could believe it if I could achieve
it because I believed it dude I'd be
like I'd be of just all winning sure
everything sure it's not that easy
yeah you got to believe it you got to
work hard at you gotta have some natural
capabilities mm-hmm it's the way it is
I'm sorry to let everyone down lose your
line is one of those lines that he gonna
take with you said belief something said
it it belief is not gonna make anything
happen
yeah at the same time without belief
nothing's gonna happen
totally true yeah yeah so yeah you've
got absolutely so yes belief by itself
won't make anything happen
yeah that you know some people sit
around yeah I believe I can do this yeah
chief no no you want to achieve you got
to do something yeah and and the same
token that is also correct is that if
you don't believe in what you're doing
then yeah there's no way you're gonna
achieve it mmm
you won't be able to cut through it when
it gets problematic which it's certainly
going to so Sachs agrees with me that
hey the work of nature has to be in play
yeah otherwise it's not happening you
might get to some level but yeah reality
is that I think the hard one to admit
you you don't seem like you want to
admit this you're over there like you if
you wanted to go the distance
put it this way I it seems really like
that's not sure it seems like you know
you maybe just didn't work hard enough
even though you thought that you worked
as hard as you possibly can maybe the
fact it is what it seems like but at the
end of the day I do agree with that I
mean it's it's way clearer with physical
stuff there's physical limitations way
more you know obvious and there's
there's I don't know well let's face it
let's say playing guitar because I play
guitar and I also now kind of play
ukulele yeah but let's say playing a
talk even if you practice and you can
mechanically play guitar that doesn't
give you the natural spark of creativity
that is demanded if it did then every
person that worked hard and played
guitar would become a rock and roll star
with great creative songs but it just
doesn't happen
yeah there's hundreds of thousands just
in America there's hundreds of thousands
of people that play guitar at an
incredibly capable proficiency right
they can play every song that you hear
on the radio but you know what they do
for a living cover cover songs well they
play cover songs they're also working as
a banker somewhere as they didn't have
whatever creative thing that would give
them to be able to create something that
was new and that people wanted wanted to
listen to that that needs to come from
somewhere else yeah in practice isn't
gonna get you there some people learn it
in the schools some people learn it on
the streets but I think you kind of got
to be born with it man and this little
tenacious d for everyone
yeah you know yeah yeah and again can't
like can you teach creativity and even
then it's like yeah but no yeah really
exactly I mean compared I lose and then
where do you get it really you know it's
a yeah it's weird it's just I think
that's really the reason that it is true
is because you can't put your finger on
it you can't be like yeah just work as
hard as you possibly can sure that's
gonna improve another classic example is
look at the people you know if I go to
an academic a high level academic
environment where everyone is you know
incredibly intelligent but not all of
them are able to do something that not
all of them are able to succeed at the
level that their that their heritage
would point towards so just because you
got up 1600 on your SATs and you did
this and you went to this great college
there's a lot of people that did all
those things and they're they're not
what they themselves would consider
successful yeah right and so the reality
is there's something not there and like
you said I don't know that you can
actually put your finger on it
yeah because there's some other kid that
didn't do any of that and made stuff
happen
yeah and was extremely successful
there's thousands and thousands of
examples like that - yeah it's so it's
kind of like when you compare it like
the proverbial person with all the
potential versus someone with not that
much potential and maybe the guy with
that with leat less potential
there'll be exceptions where that guy
made it and then they'll be obviously
like all these other scenarios where the
guy with the potential doesn't doesn't
make it so let's say alright you know
this guy's born with it what kind of
let's take it to a new level not just
making it but actually being a like the
highest level yeah for that person you
gotta have the talent and you got to
have the work you got to do both tends
to be this yeah he's check
and he says the same thing here I have
seen very good kernels become very bad
generals I have known others who were
great takers of villages excellent for
maneuvers within an army but who outside
of that were not even able to lead a
thousand men in war who lost their heads
completely and were unable to make a
decision any decision so he sees the
same thing and and you you know I see
that with business leaders the business
leader that you need to be the at the
beginning of your business is not the
same business leader that you need to be
once your business is more successful
you got to have this some guys are good
at street fighting right they're good at
street fighting they're not good at
planning a war planning a campaign and
so you might win as a company if you're
a leader at the street fighting level
and you do good you scrap it out then as
you grow if you don't transition
mentally and become a different kind of
leader not a different person but a
different kind of leader you may not be
able to win at the higher levels hmm
so that needs to get paid attention to
back to the book one should once and for
all a stab established standard combat
procedures which the troops as well as
the general who leads them no I'm not
the first person to talk about standard
operating procedures oh these are
general rules such as preserving proper
distances on the March
when charging to charge vigorously to
fill up intervals in the first line from
the second no written instructions are
required for this it is the ABC of the
troops and nothing is simpler standard
operating procedures he also says that
the general should preserve an
unfettered mind and not occupy himself
with trifles
I am convinced that a skillful general
could make war all his life without
being forced into one hmm that's the old
the real martial artist doesn't have to
fight the art of fighting without fight
here and as a yes
war can be made without leaving anything
to chance and this has and this is the
highest point of perfection and skill as
a general so he now are there things
that are left a chance in war yeah
there's a lot of things that are left a
chance in war but can you mitigate a lot
of those yeah absolutely
back to the book the words of the
proverb a bridge of gold should be made
for the enemy is followed religiously
meaning I'm gonna give if the enemy
wants to run I'm gonna build him a
bridge of gold to run on I'm not you
want to run away that's great war is
over this is false on the contrary the
pursuit should be pushed to the limit
and the retreat which had appeared such
a satisfactory solution will be turned
into a rout a detachment of ten thousand
men can destroy an army of 100,000 in
flight nothing inspires so much terror
or occasions so much damage for
everything is lost so you say no you
don't let the enemy get away when
they're running that's when you destroy
them completely this is not to say that
it is necessary to give yourself up
totally to the pursuit and follow the
enemy with all your forces but if the
officer you have ordered in pursuit
prides himself upon the regularity of
his formation and the precautions of his
March there is no use in having sent him
he must attack push and pursue without
cease all maneuvers are good then it is
only
precautions that are worthless yeah and
that right there kind of wraps up the
highlights of this book attack push
pursue without ceasing and I believe
that is also known as getting after it
in what's interesting is I think it's
clear that as we continue to see these
leaders throughout history that were
able to lead through the harshest of
conditions there's a obviously a lot of
common principles that they share and so
the question is okay why do we keep
reading them but mmm why do I keep
trying to confirm the same things why am
I always looking actually for counter
points as well that offers some kind of
different solution like the one about
Sun soo today no need to be early on the
battlefield if it's cold out there and
it's gonna wear down your troops don't
be early but from my perspective the
more different angles that you see these
things the same the the more different
ways that you learn the same lesson the
more clearly you understand if you learn
an armlock from three different people
are all gonna give you something
different and it's the same thing we get
something slightly different from all
these strategic thinkers and we get
better understanding of it and there are
differences in what people say and I
think it's good to look at the way those
differences manifest themselves on the
battlefield and throughout history
because maybe there's one solution
that's a little bit better than the one
that I know right now so for me I'm
gonna continually try to reinforce try
and fortify try and stay humble as Saks
talked about continue to learn and
relearn and discard what doesn't work
and always try and get
better and I think that's all I've got
for tonight yeah I guess it better be I
thought this was going to be a quick
episode good all right I guess we should
move quickly now what do you think
doesn't sound like see what up
so getting better yeah speaking and
getting Menon Jacques has some
supplements there Jocko supplements so
you know you're gonna get better and I
there's the case so super krill is the
krill oil supplement good one super and
joint warfare and disciplined kiss mmm
say those three so I'm sure if anyone's
wondering if you're watching on YouTube
and you're seeing me drink two things
I'm drinking two things one of them is
in a smart water bottle and it is I'm
drinking discipline the other is in a
Poland Spring bottle that I brought back
from Maine to remind me of Maine and I'm
drinking that one didn't we yeah well
they're a little northeast we'll say
yeah yeah but you won't get you won't
find Poland spring out here
no no that's right well you brought it
back just don't nonetheless so super
krill krill oil better than fish oil
factually factually and then this Jocko
super krill which is better than regular
krill oil actually no there's there's
there's people out there not taking
krill oil and I'm not saying they should
take krill oil I they should take krill
oil that's not what I'm saying right now
I am saying if I will argue I'll
actually pretty much guarantee pretty
much I know that defeats the purpose of
the guarantee but I'll pretty much
guarantee that if someone's not taking
krill oil whether you chuckle krill or
or not and they take krill oil they'll
be like dang I should have started
taking this krill oil before is it like
learning to see when you start jujitsu
oh man I just I wish I started this when
I was 13 just like that on a smaller
level yeah oh no on a joint
maintenance level yeah
joint warfare is what I'm feeling is for
me that's kind of its new right you know
and I'm like man I wish I had this for a
long wait the joint work yeah yeah
because you can feel it's like you're
getting maintenance well you should have
came up with it earlier yeah no I know
next time that's what you're gonna do
come up with it earlier that's what I
think you should do nonetheless
therefore you join to the it's a good
we're all working out they were making
something we're making a new product
will Center and it is it's gonna be good
you're gonna like it it's it's a it's a
protein drink mm-hmm and it's gonna be
uh it's I've had we've done through
samplings given the in greet you know so
we give the ingredients to the
supplement factory they mix them and
we've gone through to the we've gone
through two iterations right the first
iteration I was like oh my god this
tastes good talking pure taste test the
first one I was like all this is this
taste good really good like the kind
where you think this is a whole new
thing you know what I mean well whole
new thing like this is like yeah yeah
because protein tastes protein powders
yeah yeah he has a crap yeah and that
was one of the things we research to
figure out how we could make it taste
legit good where you not you're holding
your nose and forcing down but yeah the
first sample that we got which I was in
Maine when we tasted it we stood there
was me Brian and Pete and we were
standing there and we we all mixed it up
together and imported into three
separate cups and and everyone when we
drank and it was like quiet for a second
it was oh my God look what kind is it
well this one was mint chocolate yeah
and it's just really good and obviously
the protein is awesome and we've got
some other things in it that are gonna
make it more complete but yeah and then
I just got the sec but you know there's
a couple adjustments that I wanted to
make to the taste just the pure taste
so we just made those adjustments I got
the second iteration in it tastes even
better than the first one but I still
I've sent them back for one more
but hopefully don't only be one more
iteration before we can start producing
it's gonna not gonna come out for a
while
it takes a long time to get everything
rolling but yeah anyways we have that in
the future that's interesting because I
don't I'm not into protein I know you
are I was that you really there is this
one I'm telling you you will be your
protein it'll be for like a dessert
it'll be like someone saying they're not
into this is gonna be like someone
saying I'm not into ice cream it is good
I guess we'll see I guess that's kind of
the test right you know wait you know
wait you know well good nonetheless
krill oil joint warfare and discipline
those are already out yep doing work
discipline tastes good too
yeah that's another thing you don't have
to drink something that tastes like crap
just because it's awesome for you you
can do something that tastes good in
I'll tell you one thing I've noticed and
I don't know if this is I don't know
what this means but when I drink
discipline because some I workout in the
morning as I say all the time I don't do
a pre-workout thing it's not my thing
right I work out in the morning on an
empty stomach yeah and there's his old
rock climber and I can't think of his
name right now one of them famous old
rock climbers and he would I read an
article one time about him where he was
he would climb while starving himself
and wearing a weight belt it was harder
I was like yellow but if I've done that
all fun done never sits yeah anyways if
you have some discipline mm-hmm the
drink then you will feel like so when I
got done working out maybe like let's
say you know I would say I usually have
some nuts around some mixed nuts just to
kind of get a my gut a little food I've
been I've been having some some you know
a couple handfuls of mixed nuts and then
having some discipline you know I feel
so like super good then I'm just firing
through today and so basically what I'm
getting at is this is I've been eating
even cleaner because I'm eating like I'm
eating basically right now I think I'm
eating once a day I'm eating discipline
i'ma drink its best one and then I'm
going once a day with like a good solid
meal and then yeah it's man it's good
it's good stuff and that's good that
works for you it's working good for
because I'll tell you why when I eat
less I feel better yeah but I when I eat
less I feel better and so this is making
me eat less now I'm not saying now
believe me when I eat dude I get it on
yes that's how I roll when I eat I get
it on and but this is just yeah it's
nice to be able to get to feel energized
and sharp mentally without getting crazy
think that because you know that idea
that when you eat less and you feel
better yeah and I found that to be the
case and this is what I realized I found
that to be the case only sometimes and I
was thinking why is it like that
sometimes if I'm doing something like
you know one go to the muster or
something like that over FTX
I we're doing something all day you
don't and I wasn't eating yeah yes but
if you eat it's kind of like your body
goes into this like kind of rest mode
yeah sure but if you eat a little bit or
like just that you know just like gonna
stand oh it's time to we cruisin now
yeah yeah you rest
William any body you're basically
telling yourself you're going into level
seven echo cruise yeah technically
recover mode it's really kind of what it
does and that's really what it felt like
so yeah I found that that yeah if you so
you probably have a bunch of stuff to do
oh yeah yeah but when I'm for sure when
you're like when I'm doing a fast I want
to be doing something yeah you sit
around and think about full yet bro
that's horrible you say like like when
Charlie plum was talking about being the
Hanoi Hilton and he's just thinking of
they were just literally sitting around
thinking about food all the time because
it wasn't anything to do yeah and even
food is actually a little bit of a cure
or relief from boredom yeah you know
okay when you're kid you're just bored
you look in the fridge for you're not
hungry you're bored yeah yeah it's funny
because right now I got my kid oh my
it's wrestling season so the weight cuts
are on and they're not neither one of my
kids that are resting are cutting a
bunch of weight but it means that you
don't it means that there's times when
you don't eat for a day right thing
you get to see the effects of that and
my daughter's like I feel this is like -
you'll find she doesn't get hangry
nothing she doesn't get angry I warned
my wife I said hey you need to watch out
because when people because you mean
you're cutting weight with fighters
they're cutting much more severe weight
and they start getting in bad moods
Oh fighters yeah yeah they start getting
in bad moods because they can't eat and
they get hangry yeah but neither one of
my kids are cutting that much weight
they're just kind of maintaining through
the season dude I don't know if we
talked about hangry like that's up for
real thing because this is what it is
and you when you I mean viola
physiologically this will be your
frontal cortex or a pre frontal frontal
whatever the front of your brain the
part that's under your scientists that
needs an empathy and like all these
things get compromised one year weight
when you're what hungry oh come on man
listen to Colin listen why because it
because I believe that if you if if you
made all those things less effective
then we wouldn't be here as a species
because every time we got hungry in the
past we would have gotten all confused
and frustrated and we develop to hunt
but the bottom line is the opposite I
think is true back in the day if you
needed to hunt something down you had to
be sharp so you didn't need it made you
sharper and more tuned that's how I feel
okay that's not what you know when I
read and heard but hey I'm not saying it
weird that you can go on the internet
and find it or two scientific articles
that say the exact opposites just follow
me so hangry from what I read sighs -
correct because often Vinny's weren't
angry but om poppy and this is with like
if you get hungry or sleep-deprived
whatever this yeah just a part of your
brain kind of it doesn't shut down
completely it just because yesterday
yesterday I went to sleep I went to bed
at 8:30 at night yeah I woke up at like
350 you know it's kind of I was like
dang that felt good yeah I was but I
didn't sleep almost at all the night
before so I was recovering I needed to
put some more back in the bank and
everyone says you can't do that yeah
heavens you can't catch up on sleep I
just did
I don't know just did I brought you like
you win yeah I caught up on sleep I
never let you finish your hey your
scientific explanation so what was the
deal
3:40 so you know you'll treat people
were so technically um so yeah hangry
that's apparently from what I read is is
it now something maybe not so maybe I'm
sure aggression yeah I'm sure aggression
maybe does make you sharpen when you're
sharper you're not taking any crap from
anybody so you're more aggressive
towards them cuz you want to go on hunt
and kill something you maybe I do agree
with your weird science but nonetheless
um yeah it's a real thing apparently
okay I don't know not to say that
everyone's gonna behave in a certain way
I'm just saying that's what happened
internally maybe maybe not nonetheless
get disciplined it'll cognitively
enhance so if your prefrontal or frontal
quartet we just both of them both of is
your frontal thing in your brain is
shutting down bull and take that
discipline the cognitive enhancer is
gonna help it out a lot don't be angry
even if you're hungry guess where you
can get these things at origin man calm
there's a lot of cool stuff on there or
gin main also has geese rash guards
various clothing items all made in
America that's a good spot just check it
out look on there it's a lot of cool
stuff on there if you want something get
something also if you're into workout
equipment to populate your home gym it's
good having a home gym by the way one of
our friends is coming into town and he's
like yeah let's catch a workout we don't
have to go to a gym and catch a workout
workout at home to do something else
nonetheless it made me think of how good
it is to have a home gym nonetheless
if you have your home gym you're gonna
populate it even a little bit get your
workout stuff from on it that's what I
think it's the cool one you can do
various interesting workout routines
with the equipment
unlike Jaakko chuckles workouts are
super boring even though you do have
kettlebells which I respect
yeah and anything you want to add on
that no man that's it are you sure if it
was the workout
think about they can no no no that
kettlebell you're good you're good
you're solid
and I'm sure you get him very strong and
I'm sure you know in case everyone
doesn't know ya nuns running his mouth
and I use that term like with I'm not
just throwing it out there mm-hmm I
really was running my mouth and you're
really pissed yeah that you have a what
and how much is your heaviest cat about
ninety ninety ninety-five Bigfoot boom
and my heaviest kettlebell was 88 pounds
this is no longer a problem now my
heaviest kettlebells plural because I
have to do is 48 kilograms or 106 pounds
commonly referred to as the beast
nonetheless minor from on it they're the
cool ones and you can get other cool
exercise stuff there so go on it calm
slash jaco check out the stuff there you
want some get something also when you
get your copy of reveries on the art of
war by Maurice de sacs so good on I
liked those manual kind ones you know
one that goes yeah but I know it's if
you think about it there's really three
types of podcasts that are happening one
is Qun a two is manual strategies about
war three is human nature inside war so
those are kind of yeah when I'm reading
a book I'm like I only know is just kind
of like one of those yeah yeah so this
would be with Napoleon's Maxim's yeah
yeah something like that the art of war
by Sun Tzu so we have done quite a
number of books like that yes and you
know I get a little something different
from each of them because if you think
about it he says that you have to pay
attention to the human heart well we're
gonna learn about the human heart and he
didn't say much about as much as he said
you need to know about it he didn't say
much about it where you gonna find it
gonna find it by reading people that
were actually in war and start to
understand where their heart was in this
whole gig yeah
yes interesting too because they're laid
out in these specific contexts you know
like um like Sun Tzu that he's talking
about you know a certain time period a
certain place and then you see a Vietnam
one and then
and so they're talking about okay these
principles at this time yes is why they
were well it was interesting to do I
drank and how more because it was his
battle to podcasts on his battle and
then his book that he wrote about
leadership so you kind of got to see
maybe I don't know I don't know if
there's anything now we've seen some of
that when for instance you got
Napoleon's Maxim's right and then we got
to hear from a Napoleonic foot soldier
so you get to kind of see see the war
what the war was like what the human
heart was what's going on with the human
heart and then what was going on with
the minds of the strata station yeah I
don't know if that's a word it's tragic
sure I think so just became you know
what's cool is the English language you
can words they they come about you guys
get formed yeah that's a kiss there's a
time where there was no word and then
that word is there yeah well if you
learned
oh he which is the Oxford English
Dictionary it tells you where the word
came from and then it has like first
usages so there's some worse this word
is this firt this word was first in
print in 1622 in this work of art or
this work of literature yeah you know
it's crazy cheese like words will go in
these cycles where they'll be used like
like ain't right if you say ain't that's
an improper thing it's not really a word
level by ain't was actually used by like
high upper-class people back in the day
a long time ago and like ain't and
shan't in all these like words like I
[__] you know all this 1/8 was one of
them there's one of them and I forget
the deal but someone in the lower class
started using it and they're like oh
they're using it now or something like
that so it went out and now it's like oh
that's not a word it is a word the ink
the language in general but definitely
the English language I studied English
in college and but the the classes that
I took some of the classes that I took
would focus on that which was pretty is
always very interesting to me very
interesting to me and I think the reason
it's interesting to me is because
language is how weak
Kate communication is how we lead yeah
so if you don't know what words you're
using or you can't find the right word
to articulate what it is you're trying
to say you know harder time getting your
message across when you have a harder
time getting your message across it's
harder for you to lead it yeah so and
then if you kind of look at the big
picture of that it's kind of like you
have been then you kinda in a way should
know slang and stuff like that for sure
for shows if you're over your talking
quote/unquote all proper to people who
aren't used to here is your property
thinking like what's this guy talking
about or whatever that is definitely
true and it's not just about language
there it's about culture as well yeah
and and you know one of the cool things
that when I grew up and I was kind of
you know getting into the heart and I
was in the hardcore scene right it
exposed me to people and things that I
wouldn't have seen if I would have
stayed in my small New England town so
when I got to the world meaning got out
of that small town and now I was in the
military I was able to understand better
than I would have if I didn't yeah I
think that's important yeah yeah it
helps for sure you have okay how's this
word irregardless irregardless it's not
even a word right that's what they said
so I had this bet this a long time was
like over ten years ago
I just bet it's a co-worker of mine and
I for whatever I think my dad taught me
like your girl is not a word you know
and he'd always like correct you so you
know I had imprints in your mind like
someone uses the word irregardless they
should be corrected that was kind of
imprinted in my subconscious so it
happened at work echo Charles grammar
not a little bit one but nonetheless he
know she was a girl I said irregardless
is not a word and she was like yeah it
is I was like no irregardless is like a
misuse misuse of a word right it regards
regardless irregardless is a misuse of
words none where he's like well if it's
a if it's a work if it's a misuse of a
word it's the word for the misuse of
this specific word and I'm like it's not
a worry that he'll did that just mean
yeah but she's
she's saying basically if you can say it
and you can smell it and it's like if
it's a little name for something it's
not the name of it it's the name for a
misuse of a word is what that was her
argument did you win money no I did not
know myself money no so we're we it
never got resolved between me and her
and we hated me I think we kind of hated
each other yeah but nonetheless that was
her stance my stance is you can't just
invent a word you can't just use a word
wrong invent another word because you're
wrong and then be like oh now it's a
word now I'm right all of us and you
can't do that's not how it works and
then so I look it up in the dictionary
hey yeah I was haunting me so when I
went oh I looked it up in the dictionary
sure enough the thing was there and it
said the misuse of the word or the
common misuse of regardless some but I
still confused like is that a word and
here's the thing I talk to Jade about it
yeah it bothered me a lot yeah so I
talked to Jade about and he was like
bruh that's kind of how the language is
he's right yet enough people misusing
regardless same irregardless boom all of
a sudden it gets shuffled right into the
rotation as a legitimate words what is
that a good thing or is that about a
what it's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing it is if the language is
always evolving and that's what allows
the language just like just like jujitsu
just like a mixed martial arts you want
it to evolve you want it to new words to
come out that can articulate something a
little bit better you like for instance
irregardless articulates it you know
being grease language very well yeah but
but yeah at some point a hundred years
in the future irregardless will become a
word that has a little bit of a
different meaning than regardless like
it's maybe it's more regardless like
irregardless of what you're saying and
it will say first used in the you know
somebody's gonna write an article in
online or and it's gonna say the guy's
gonna misuse it but it everyone's gonna
understand it it doesn't say first used
here yeah there's all kinds of argument
you can have about language but you have
to remember that it's evolving all the
time our language is revolving all time
and it should in France they try not to
let their language evolve
yeah then I try and keep that language
it's interesting or the ultimate result
is something like that would be a
brother the word I think it's the same
result if you try and not not evolve
your martial arts yeah actually if you
don't evolve your martial arts you're
gonna lose yeah yes the same thing with
language yeah you become less effective
communication wise yeah in the language
as far as that goes the word literally
no okay literally we know what like hey
here's the hard part about accepting
this because literally means something
very specific
there's no ambiguous Ness if it started
to be ambiguous
you wouldn't say literally yes they
figuratively or you just won't say
anything that's what you'd that's um
that's the defining characteristic of
the word literally but here's the thing
now literally doesn't mean literally
literally means just almost a lot yeah
just really strong not even almost
lyrics just really strong so if I was
like man this guy's joke was so funny I
I was literally dying alright
I wasn't almost dying it's not what it
means it just means it was super duper
duper funny yeah you know that's not
what's changing yeah man but that's a
hard one to accept like and all I think
there's another word but in America and
California siz a recent one so maybe the
80s everyone stood in order to say said
said like or all NACA was like you got
to stop doing this and I was all no way
I'm gonna do that that's just the way
clang Guevarra yeah dang that's cool hey
man I dig it
so nonetheless if you want to buy this
book
regardless irregardless of the language
in it don't do that what I did was I
made it easy you go to jakka podcast
calm on the top menu whatever put a page
there has all the books by episode this
one is on there along with everything
else just click through there it's a
good way to support and you get you
takes you to Amazon you get your book
and eight hours however long it takes to
ship to your house good way to support
also if you're doing other shopping if
you're gonna buy that lawnmower and leaf
blower that you've been meaning to buy
and the rake is well
just saying you're in the wrong time
zone ever wrong time of year for this oh
yeah wait the rake no it's about to be
spring so what you got another six
months before you get the rake out in
the lawn blower yeah I just that's one
of the last things that I bought with a
leaf blower really yeah okay long story
nonetheless duct tape that's year-round
thing yeah so if you get duct tape just
carry on chopping whatever you want to
do that's what that's what you do good
way to support also subscribe to the
podcast iTunes get your Google Play
Spotify or wherever else they have
podcasts and wherever else you want
listen to the podcast they have like new
podcasts apps out to yeah they all have
them though yeah and I dig it so hey
whatever you're using to listen so it's
great so good seems obvious I guess on
the listening part but YouTube's not so
much we have a YouTube channel subscribe
to that too that's a good way to support
if you want some people not into YouTube
who's not into YouTube I don't know but
you have some good information on you
can also waste a bunch of time on it
yeah yeah it's like just it's yeah it's
like the Internet in general you know a
lot of stuff your whole like pursuit can
be on the internet and it can be very
beneficial at the same time your whole
pursuit can be in the Internet where you
do and it can be detriment in your
pursuit like whatever you're trying to
do going on the internet will basically
make it out so like if you're trying to
if you're trying to learn 3d modeling go
on the internet you can learn 3d
modeling 100% not 100% but you can learn
to be a professional 3d modeler on the
Internet at the same time you get caught
up watching some nonsense and not even
take one step towards 3d modeling or so
what I'm saying it's the dichotomy of
the internet YouTube has the same
dichotomy but if you subscribe to the
jockle podcast YouTube channel there's
no dichotomy they're all good all good
is that upside because it has video
versions podcast it has excerpts and as
various other little videos we'll just
sort of add mm-hmm
I always say I'm gonna add but this time
I think I'm really and adds a different
type of the video you'll see good anyway
good way to support also jaw close the
store if you didn't already know
it's called jaw closed or
chuckles I'll come that's where you can
get the shirt that jockle is wearing
right now
victory MMA and fitness you have to be a
member of the victory Emma Mayen Fitness
you if you have the shirt you're kind of
a member yeah at least in spirit you
know you're a member in you know yeah in
that sort of way nonetheless it's on
jock host Ericom that's where you can
get any of the shirts that we make and
so we also have hoodies on there and
rash guards and hats and patches a lot
of good stuff kids women's good so I'm
not saying to go buy something I'm not
saying that I'm saying go there
chocolates or to come check out the
stuff you want something get something
and that's a good way to support also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is which I know you do but in
the unlikely event of you not knowing
what that is this is what it is it's an
album not a music album
it's a spoken word album with tracks
Jaakko helping us through weak points of
our day weak points of our campaign
against weakness weak points of our
struggle struggle good strolls struggle
for good sure struggle for good that's
what it is you know the day you want to
uni you want to sleep in or you want to
cheat on the day you want to
procrastinate you want to skip the
workout that's the mean one that's
iconic one the other day
a good one didn't skip it psychological
warfare that's on iTunes it helps you
through it yeah some people they don't
know so it's jock on each track Wow I'm
telling you sometimes they're like wait
what did I didn't hear that of this it's
like college core yeah we're not gonna
listen to the rest of this podcast
right they will it only has like two
minute three for like 25 minutes left
I'm just saying it's like psychological
warfare is good what's done if you want
Jocko to help you just put it in that's
how it originated you don't me nuts give
workouts you can get it on iTunes you
get on Amazon music you can get on
Google Play and other podcasting or
other mp3
platforms providing platforms also if
you're on Amazon you can get something
called jock a white tee if you don't
want to have your deadlift increased to
a minimum of eight thousand pounds then
don't get jock white tea you can get the
books yeah the books that we cover on
the podcast which are all listed on the
website you can also get a couple books
that you might want to check out one of
us called way of the war your kid I
actually wrote that book it teaches kids
to make their lives better to get on the
path and work hard there's another book
coming out it's actually available on
Amazon right now well you can't get it
yet but you can pre-order it if you want
to spread the word you preorder it that
makes more people see it so that's cool
it's called away the warrior Kid marks
mission nice little follow-up to way the
warrior kid different lessons to be
learned so you can check that off if you
want to check out an actual warrior kid
you can go and get some Jacko's soap
from young Aidan twelve years old no big
deal you know Dee's doing making soap
has his own business you can get that at
Irish Oaks ranch com like I said a
twelve-year-old kid making goat milk
soap you know why you know I did that
you can't sell goat milk in California
yeah but you can't sell goat soap yeah
yeah so he wanted to make some good ones
so you can check that out as well the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
about getting after it there's really
nothing more to say
if you I've gotten a lot of great
feedback from that book so I appreciate
it and once you feel that you've gotten
what you can out of it loan it to
somebody so they can get on the path to
maybe they'll get their own or get it
for them whatever to your choice
the important part of that everyone
wants the audio version of that book the
discipline equals freedom field manual
is not on audible it's on iTunes Amazon
music Google Play other mp3 platforms
and it also is an album that has tracks
some people say with tracks extreme
ownership the new edition is out thank
you for helping us put the new to get
new edition together because we've got
questions from this podcast a new Ford
but we've also got pictures for
questions from the podcast in their
stream ownership combat leadership how
to get out there and lead and win for
on-site leadership instruction and
consulting you can bring our company a
chillon front to your organization we
solve problems through leadership simple
as that you got a problem the way be the
problem solved is through leadership
it's me
it's Lafe babban it's JP Danelle it's
Dave Burke email info national on front
comm or you can go through the website
Ashlin front comm there's also the
muster leadership seminar with the
echelon front team we're only doing two
this year I'm gonna try and get a bunch
of questions that I get asked all the
time I'm gonna try and get rid of those
questions right now we're only doing two
musters this year we aren't going to New
York City we aren't going to Texas we
aren't going to Florida we aren't going
to your hometown I'm sorry we just can't
we can't go to every town in America to
do a muster we're only doing two of them
this year we're doing one in Washington
DC so there's the East Coast and the
West Coast one is in Washington DC it's
May 17th and 18th we're doing another
one in San Francisco October 17th and
18th so if you want to come to a muster
you got to come to one of those too
we're not going to Omaha we're not going
to Milwaukee I want to go there but
unfortunate we can't just get to all
those different places so apologize thus
far there has been four musters that
we've done over the past year and a half
they all sold out these two musters are
going to sell out as well so if you want
to come
and you want to learn pragmatic
leadership skills and strategies then
you can go to extreme ownership calm and
you can register we will see you there
echo Charles will also be there and
until you get to the muster if you have
questions for us or you have answers for
us we're looking for both we're here and
we are cruising hard actually on the
interwebs on Twitter Instagram and on
Daath Baja echo is at Echo Charles and I
am at Jocko willing and finally thanks
to those people out there that make this
podcast possible and by that I mean
first and foremost our military men and
women who go into harm's way to protect
our freedom and our way of life thanks
to you and also to the police out there
holding the thin blue line thanks for
protecting us here on the home front to
the firefighters paramedics and other
first responders thanks for being ready
to come out and rescue us anytime day or
night and to everyone else that is
listening thank you for listening thank
you for sharing thank you for supporting
the podcast cuz we appreciate we
appreciate all that but more important
we appreciate going down this path with
all of you so keep putting one foot in
front of the other as you move down this
path keep making the decisions the right
decisions even on the little things keep
attacking pushing pursuing without cease
and most of all keep getting after it so
until next time this is echo and Jocko
Oh